Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pretluff und ich begrüße alle hier zu einer weiteren
Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe, in der wir ja ins Weltall eintauchen und heute äh tauchen wir mal so richtig äh in die Tiefen des Weltalls und greifen ein Thema auf, was ich tatsächlich schon mal
behandelt hatte, nämlich äh das Thema der Neutrondensterne. Da hatte ich mich in Romzeit Nummer 76 mit äh Konstantina,
schon ausführlich mal drüber unterhalten und vor allem so ein bisschen die äh
Perspektive der Kernphysiker eingenommen. Heute wollen wir uns dem Thema nochmal nähern, nämlich aus einer anderen Richtung und äh dazu bin ich nach Barcelona gefahren.
Und äh zwar an das äh wie es so schön heißt, Institut des Jens hier ist Les Pay.
Also kurz gesagt, dass äh Institut for Space Sciences, wie das so in international heißt und äh
grüßt meine Gesprächspartnerin heute, nämlich Vanessa Graber, hallo.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist hier ähm ja Forscherin an diesem Institut. Ähm ich weiß gar nicht seit wann eigentlich schon.
Eine Woche bevor der erste Lockdown hier angefangen hat.
Also seit knapp zwei Jahren sozusagen. Alles klar. Äh ja offiziell heißt das dann hier Senior Post Doktor Researcher äh ist immer schöne Bezeichnung. Und äh steht aber demnächst ein Upgrade an.
Ich habe mein eigenes Fellowship gewonnen, das am 1. Mai anfängt. Das ist eines der spanischen Busdoktor Fellows.
Das heißt, man ist ja irgendwie gefördert.
Genau, also man kann sich dafür bewerben. Ähm im Moment laufe ich noch am Projekt meiner Chefin mit. Ähm und bin da als eingestellt und ab dem 1. Mai kann ich quasi, also ich habe mich beworben mit einem eigenen Forschungsprojekt, das ich dann für drei Jahre am 1. Mai anfangen werde.
Gut und du bist ähm theoretische Physikerin und äh hast äh Narren gefressen an,
Ähm ich würde gern mal so ein bisschen zurückspulen erstmal äh wie es denn mit dir mit Wissenschaft überhaupt äh begonnen hat. Frühe Liebe, späte Liebe.
Also Wissenschaft würde ich sagen tatsächlich Frühliebe? Ähm,
Ich mochte Physik und machte in der Schule immer sehr, sehr, sehr gerne, ähm hatte aber nicht so wirklich eine Ahnung, wie Physiker tatsächlich arbeiten, ähm meisten Schüler haben das ja oder eher nicht, weil in der Schule ist das ja doch eher doch so ein bisschen ja hier haben wir XY, das lernt ihr jetzt mal.
Aber wie das dann tatsächlich funktioniert später, ähm wenn man sich damit
so von Tag zu Tag beschäftigt, ist ja doch immer nicht ganz so klar. Ähm aber ich glaube, ich habe zum ersten Mal die Frage beantwortet, was ich denn gerne machen würde später, da war ich ungefähr vierzehn. Ähm und da habe ich gesagt, ich würde gerne theoretische Physikerin werden.
Ohne wirklich eine Ahnung davon zu.
Einfach mal was raushauen.
Was raushauen, ja. Das ist aber tatsächlich so geblieben und ich habe dann nach dem Abi beschlossen, ich versuche das mal. Ich fange mal an, Physik zu studieren.
Nur gemacht, weil sie es einmal, weil sie sich einmal verplappert hast.
Also ich würde sagen nicht verplappert, das war schon so ein Interesse. Also ich wollte früher davor wollte ich immer Lehrerin werden und das ist auch immer noch so ein Teil, was mir an dem Wissenschaftleralltag auch sehr Spaß macht, die Lehrer an sich.
Das ist also nicht so nicht so anders in mancher Hinsicht, aber das ist schon auch so geblieben. Also das war nicht so, dass da noch viele anderen Sachen während dem Teenageralter irgendwie mal eingeflossen sind.
Okay, also keine Hollywood-Karriere war.
Das war jetzt dann eher nicht so mein Fall, nein.
Aber Astronautin wolltest du auch nicht.
Nee, da ist auch nicht, nee muss ich sagen, da bleibe ich lieber mit den Füßen auf der Erde.
Aber mit dem Kopf in den Sternen.
Und wie kam's dann äh zu Barcelona als er jetzt ähm dieses spanischen Institut, da habe ich so gelernt, die sind ja dann auch sehr,
sag mal so salopp, äh sehr national orientiert, tun sehr viel dafür, dass so die lokalen Wissenschaftler hier eine Rolle spielen und ich habe immer so den Eindruck da äh internationale Anteil ist jetzt nicht ganz so hoch, wie man das in Deutschland sieht.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Also,
Ähm das kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, in welchem Fachbereiche man ist, würde ich sagen. Also in der theoretischen Astrophysik und in der Astronomie im Allgemeinen ist es schon sehr häufig der Fall, dass man sehr, sehr, sehr selten,
an der gleichen Stelle bleibt für seine gesamte Forscherkarriere. Ähm das heißt bei uns oder in meinem Fachbereich ist es schon normal, dass man so ein bis zwei oder drei Posts macht, bevor man dann tatsächlich irgendwie eine feste Stelle oder eine Stelle bekommt,
Das heißt, ähm nachdem ich in Deutschland Physik studiert habe und in Tübingen meine Diplomarbeit zu Neuronenstern geschrieben habe.
Wusste ich, dass ich weiter an dem Thema arbeiten wollte ähm und habe dann quasi nach,
Doktorarbeiten zu diesem Thema gesucht ähm und ihn auch in der Richtung, in der ich mich schon oder für die ich mich spezialisiert hatte, damit das vielleicht nachher noch ein bisschen reden können und dann,
habe ich eine Stelle angeboten bekommen für eine Doktorarbeit in Southempton in England. Da war ich dann vier Jahre und danach habe ich eine dreijährige Posttele in Montreal in Kanada,
erledigt und seit zwei Jahren ungefähr bin ich jetzt hier in Barcelona.
Okay, also kommst ganz gut rum. Und womit hat sich dann diese Doktorarbeit.
Der Titel meiner Doktorarbeit war komplex. Also ich habe mich mit kosmischen Kondensaten beschäftigt.
Das im Prinzip bedeutet, dass ähm Neutonsterne in ihrem Innern ein Quantenmechanischen Zustand,
innehalten und das ist quasi das Cosmic Content Sales und diese Zustände sind relativ ähnlich mit Kontenzuständen, die wir auf der Erde beschreiben,
Labor realisieren können und ich habe mich quasi dann versucht so diese diese Brücke zu schlagen zwischen dem Laborsystem und dem Neuronensternsystem.
Und wie bist du darauf gekommen? Also ich meine.
Darauf gekommen. Ähm also meine meine Masterarbeit war tatsächlich auch schon zu dem Thema. Also manchmal ist das ja so, wenn man irgendwie keine Ahnung hat so als Student, was man so gerne machen würde.
Da muss man sich so ein bisschen auf die Einflüsse der Professoren verlassen. Und ich hatte absolut keine Ahnung über Astronomie in Astrophysik bis Mitte meines,
Studios würde ich mal sagen. Also ich gehöre tatsächlich zu den Menschen, die vielleicht gerade noch Planeten benennen konnten. Das war's dann auch schon wieder,
Ähm aber ich hatte ähm also als ich in Tübingen studiert habe, gab's drei Spezialisierungen. Man konnte computational Physix machen, Technologie und Astronomen Astro für sechs.
Habe mich damals noch nicht so viel mit Computern beschäftigt, wie ich das heute mache ähm und Nanotechnologie war nicht so richtig mein Fall, das heißt.
Dann einfach nichts anderes übrig.
Muss ich ganz ehrlich im ersten Moment so sagen, der blieb da nichts.
Aber ich habe mich dann auch schon ähm nachdem ich dann so ein, zwei ähm drei Vorlesungen gehört habe, war mir schon klar, okay, das macht super viel Spaß.
Einem meiner Vorlesungen das war eine Vorlesung zur äh Sternenentwicklung, wurde das Thema Neutonsteine das erste Mal angesprochen,
Professoren zeigen gerne so dieses ah meistens ist da eine Folie in oder an der Tafel steht dann irgendwo so eine Tonsteine in der Mitte und dann stehen diese ganzen ähm Fächer, die man irgendwie,
können muss oder verstehen muss, um das Thema Neuronenstern zu sehen, stillen dann irgendwie außen rum und.
Ich bezeichne mich eigentlich immer als theoretische Astrophysikerin, weil ich mich im Thema der Astronomie oder Astrophysik beschäftige, aber
verschiedene theoretische, physikalische
Konzepte benutze. Also dann kommt da irgendwo konditionierter Materie vor, Festkörperphysik, genug Lehrphysik, Astronomie an sich, Astrophysik, Plasmaphysik. Für diese ganzen physikalischen Sachen, die man bei unserem Grundstudium irgendwie so unabhängig voneinander lernt.
Sich immer fragt, wozu eigentlich.
Eigentlich genau und die auch also das ist einfach die Sache des Studiums, dass man die halt nebeneinander lernt und nicht unter Umständen miteinander verschränkt. Und für mich war irgendwie klar, als wir das erste Mal über Neutonsterne geredet haben,
Dass das das Thema ist, wo das irgendwie alles zusammenfließt.
Sozusagen auch das das das theoretische Kondensat zum kosmischen.
Zum genau in der Hinsicht und das hat für mich einfach irgendwie das ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass man Offenbarung, aber es war schon irgendwie ein Thema, wo ich dachte, okay,
wenn ich mich mit dem Thema äh Wissenschaft weiter beschäftigen werde, dann will ich das machen. Und dann habe ich mir eine Diplomarbeit zu dem Thema gesucht,
Und die hat sich dann tatsächlich auch schon das erste Mal mit einem oder einem Superleiter beschäftigt. Ich muss aber sagen, ich hätte das wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht, wenn ich während meines Studiums nicht auch noch nebenher in einer Arbeitsgruppe gearbeitet hat, die sich tatsächlich.
Laborkondensaten beschäftigt hat. Also ich war als angestellt in der Arbeitsgruppe, in der man die.
Fallen für atomare Gase, ultrakalte Gase. Ähm versucht hat zu modellieren und zu optimieren und ich war da eingegliedert als Hiwi. Das heißt, ich hatte schon mal so ein bisschen was gehört von dem ganzen,
ähm theoretischen Hintergrund und das war nicht völlig neu, weil sehr oft, wenn man irgendwie nur sich mit der Astrophysik oder Astronomie beschäftigt und dann in die theoretische Physik abschweifen muss, ähm dann kommt das teilweise bei manchen Leuten nicht so gut an, aber ich kam quasi von der anderen Seite.
Ich wusste, dass ich was theoretisches machen will, aber ich wollte mich irgendwie nicht nur auf einen Fachbereich festlegen. Das heißt, es wurden dann irgendwie die Nutnetronensterne.
Ist es nicht ein bisschen so, dass eigentlich so auch die ganze ich meine, die theoretische Physik ist, es scheint ja ein sehr
wie soll ich sagen? Immer wenn ich so mit Physikern spreche, dann ist man so diese Unterscheidung experimentell oder ist ganz wichtig. So, also es,
Die Leute sind dann immer entweder im einen Anlage oder dem anderen, aber so beides zusammen in einem scheint irgendwie nicht so richtig zu gehen. Keine Ahnung, was hast du für Spielchen gespielt werden?
Trotzdem ist ja irgendwie nachvollziehbar, dass manche vielleicht so mir den Hang zu knallbum äh haben und andere wollen halt irgendwie äh dit verstehen und wollen irgendwie auch neue Modelle äh entwickeln und sich jetzt nicht einfach dadurch limitieren
lassen, was wir jetzt konkret messen kann, sondern in gewisser Hinsicht schaut man ja auch ein bisschen in die Zukunft und ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass er eigentlich die theoretische Physik
Meine Physik ist schon an sich schon so ein mega durchgespieltes äh Ding, auch wenn jetzt natürlich immer noch ein paar große äh äh Rätsel offen sind, ganz klar, aber gerade diese offenen Fragen
scheinen ja irgendwie nur im All wirklich beantwortet werden zu können oder zumindest spielt es all eine sehr große Rolle,
weiß nicht. Hast du da eine Position zu?
Ich würde sagen die Art des Arbeitens ist sehr unterschiedlich, also zwischen Experimarphy und theoretischer Physik. Ich glaube, daher kommt so dieses.
Dieses Hickhack, das ist da teilweise noch da tatsächlich gibt weil.
Also ich kann persönlich für mich sagen, ich könnte niemals in einem Labor stehen und an einem Experimentsatz rumdrehen, das kann ich einfach nicht. Da würde ich die Geduld verlieren. Da würde das nicht funktionieren. Und ich bin nicht völlig unbegabt, was irgendwie so kleine Dinge angeht, aber dafür habe ich einfach keine Geduld.
Wenn man mir ein Stück Papier gibt und eine Gleichung, da könnte ich mich tagelang damit beschäftigen, diese Gleichen zu lösen oder wenn mir jemand am Computerprogramm gibt, wenn ich versuchen muss, irgendwas,
programmieren. Das kann ich auch tagelang, aber diese Art des Arbeitens im Experimentellen, das ist schon sehr unterschiedlich. Deshalb gibt's so diese, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, zwei Lager, weil mittlerweile ist das doch irgendwie schon so ein übergreifend zwischen den zwei einzelnen Bereichen gibt,
Leute auch wirklich irgendwie versuchen,
Weise beides zu tun, wenn jemand ein Experiment durchführt, dann muss man das auch irgendwie interpretieren können. Das sorgt meistens dafür, dass man irgendwie die Theorie verstanden haben muss. Aber in gewisser Weise sind da schon so so ähm.
Wo man irgendwie seine eigenen Interessen, die man gerne arbeitet, doch irgendwie besser ausleben kann, wenn man eben in der experimentalphysik oder theoretischen Physik ist, würde ich sagen. Ähm,
und ich ich würde nicht sagen, dass es nur noch oder die großen Fragen, die dann offen stehen, dass man die nur noch im astrophysikalischen oder im astronomischen irgendwie lösen kann. Ich habe teilweise das Gefühl, das ist einfach,
worüber man in so einem Allgemein in der Wissenschaftskommunikation einfach besser einfacher reden kann. Also zum Beispiel irgendwie Dinge in der kondensierten Materie zu erklären ist unter Umständen deutlich schwieriger,
Also es ist über Sterne zu reden und irgendwie ein astronomisches oder astrophysikalisches Problem zu erklären. Also ich habe teilweise dieses Gefühl,
die expomentalphysiker, die sich mit einem Laborexperiment beschäftigen in schwierigeren Start haben als die Astrophysiker und die Astronomen in gewisser Hinsicht.
Weil da mehr Mythos dran klebt.
Also es ist schon so ein ureigenes also jeder mit jeder Person, die ich rede ähm über Astronomien, Astrophysik, dass immer sofort so ein Wow,
Und ich glaube experimentalphysiker haben dann deutlich schwierigeren Start in mancher Hinsicht, als man das so als Astronomen.
Podcast über und nicht über Materialforschung.
Ja oder.
Auch sehr interessant ist.
Ja, aber mancher Hinsicht müsste man eigentlich sagen, ähm dass so die direkte Anwendung dessen, was man irgendwie in einem Labor macht, in der Materialfäschung viel, viel direkter übertragbar ist zu unserem alltäglichen Leben eigentlich, als es das irgendwie Astronomien erst häufig ist.
Deshalb würde ich sagen ich habe dann einfacheren Start oder die Astronomen haben dann einfach einen Staat als manch andere physikalischen Fachbereiche.
Und macht's das Institut äh einfach hier auch dann äh entsprechend interdisziplinär auch zu arbeiten.
Also wir haben ähm gehören offiziell zum ähm spanischen Wirtschafts- und Forschungsministerium also wir sind so ein bisschen als Institut ähnlich wie ein Max-Planck-Institut in Deutschland,
wo quasi Forscher permanent eingestellt werden und nicht Lehre betreiben müssen. Also ähm die arbeiten quasi,
Ausschließlich an der Forschung. Wir stehen allerdings direkt im Wissenschaftsministerium unter. Und es gibt.
Mehrere hunderte von diesen Instituten jeweils auf einen bestimmten Fachbereich angeschlossen,
und wir hier ähm haben drei Unterbereiche, ein Teil Bauteleskope oder Teleskopteile,
Ein Teil beschäftigt sich mit Kosmologie und dann gibt's einen Astrophysik und High Energy für sechs Bereich, in dem ich quasi bin und wir sind.
Ähm.
In unserer Arbeitsgruppe selber, also ich bin im Moment noch angegliedert an einen, also ein europäisches Projekt, das meine äh Chefin gewonnen hat vor ein paar Jahren. Ähm und wir sind in der Arbeitsgruppe ungefähr zwölf Leute, glaube ich, im Moment.
Das Coole ist, dass wir sowohl Theoretiker als auch Astronomen haben, also die sich quasi mit Beobachtungsdaten beschäftigen, weil sie selber so irgendwie auch dieses komplette Bild
gerne sieht und nicht nur mit Leuten arbeitet, die genau das Gleiche machen wie sie. Ähm das heißt, wir kommen von sehr unterschiedlichen Bereichen. Also wir in unserer Arbeitsgruppe,
haben schon sehr großen ähm Wissens,
abgedeckt, ähm aber alles irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen im Bezug auf die Neutronenstelle und dann gibt's auch noch ähm diverse andere Arbeitsgruppen hier, mit denen wir uns irgendwie regelmäßig austauschen. Seit letzter Woche Freitag haben wir unser,
freitagliches Pizza-Seminar tatsächlich wieder in Person mit Pizza nach zwei Jahren.
Ja, das macht langsam alles wieder auf. Das ist äh sehr schön. Ähm wie groß ist das Institut hier so insgesamt? Das ist ja hier auch noch mal so eingebettet in so einem wissenschaftlichen Campus hier im Norden der Stadt.
Campus der autonomen Universität in Barcelona gehören aber nicht offiziell zur Uni. Ähm aber das Institut ist quasi aufm Gelände ähm und,
es gibt ungefähr so zwischen 60 und 70 Festangestellten, glaube ich, ungefähr zehn administrative Angestellte.
Weiß gar nicht genau, wie viel Posters wir mal haben oder so um die 20 würde ich sagen und dann nochmal eine ungefähr ähnliche Anzahl an ähm Doktoranden.
Also überschaubar, sagen wir mal.
Kommen wir mal zu den Notronensternen und den Notronensterne sind ja so ein bisschen wie auch die,
schwarzen Löcher so ein bisschen etwas, was eben auch erstmal in der Theorie erdacht,
wurde. Man hat sich halt irgendwie die physikalischen Gesetze angeschaut, spätestens seitdem irgendwie Einstein da mal ordentlich durchgewischt hat, hat sich daraus ja einfach sehr viel auch ergeben und so nach dem Motto aha okay, wir wissen jetzt, dass die Grundlagen
so sind,
Das jetzt mal wirklich durchrechnen, dann kommen wir so auf so ein paar was ist denn damit? Wann war denn eigentlich dieser Begriff Neutronenstern das erste Mal überhaupt in der Welt und wodurch?
Ich hole ein bisschen aus. Also das Wort Neutronenstern sagt uns ja eigentlich schon ein bisschen was über den Stern an sich,
Das Wort Neutron steckt da drin, das heißt, in einem Neuronenstern heißt deshalb Neutonstern, weil er zu einem großen Teil aus Neutonnen besteht,
Jetzt muss man sich so ein bisschen vor Augen führen, dass erst vor ungefähr 100 Jahren das Neuton als Teilchen,
tatsächlich vorhergesagt wurde. Also das Teilchen an sich wissen wir erst, dass es exitiert seit ungefähr hundert Jahren. Danach ging's aber ziemlich rasant weiter, aber,
also diese diese 100 Jahre ist nicht unbedingt eine lange Zeitskala auf astronomischen Skalen. Also wir wissen wirklich noch nicht so lange, dass das überhaupt existiert.
Kurz nach dieser Entdeckung des Neuthrons unter Vorhersagen haben sich Bade und Sicky,
mit dem Konzept beschäftigt, was denn tatsächlich passiert, wenn große Sterne,
Die Sonne ist ein Stern, aber wir brauchen um Neutonnensternen herzustellen was, was ungefähr acht bis zwanzig Mal so schwer ist und die haben sich quasi mit dem Konzept beschäftigt, was denn mit diesem Rosenstern massereichen Stern passiert, wenn der ähm seinen,
Brennstoff völlig verbrannt hat und haben quasi.
Versucht zu beschreiben, wie das passiert und haben quasi dieses Konzept der Supernova entwickelt und haben dann auch festgestellt, dass das Endprodukt einer solchen Supernova quasi an Neutronenstern sein kann.
Zwar in den 30ern, also kurz nachdem wir das neu tun an sich entdeckt haben, wurde dann auch quasi theoretisch vorhergesagt,
Konzept eines Nordronensterns im All im Prinzip geben könnte.
Aber aus welcher Betrachtung heraus ergibt sich äh diese Feststellung.
Im Prinzip muss man sich quasi vor Augen halten, ähm was denn mit Materie passiert, wenn sie unter bestimmten Zuständen unter bestimmte Zustände gesetzt wird. Also wir haben hier ähm relativ hohe Dichten,
Temperaturen und im Prinzip aufgrund des Verständnis, was man damals hatte über wie Materie sich unter bestimmten Zuständen verhält, konnte man quasi dann.
Gedankenstrang entlang gehen und quasi sagen, das Endprodukt im Prinzip für bestimmte Ausgangsprodukte muss erneutronenstern sein. Also,
was wie ich grad gesagt habe, wir brauchen ungefähr so was, das hat so, sagen wir mal, zwanzig Sonnenmassen. Wenn 20 Sonnenmassen existieren, dann hat das schon mal eine riesige Gravitationsanziehung, also das ist nicht so, dass das einfach nur,
da sitzt,
ähm und einfach nur ruhig ist im Prinzip, sondern wenn man so viel Masse eigentlich hat, dann würde das eigentlich gerne in sich zusammen kollabieren.
Also es gibt ja massig Sterne dieser Größenordnung, das ist ja quasi nix äh so also so ein unsere Sonne ist ja eh eher so unter ferner Liefen, aber auch so zwanzig Sonnenmassen, keine Ahnung wie groß da der Anteil ist, aber ich würde mal sagen, es gibt eine Menge davon.
Eine Menge davon, obwohl also je mehr Masse reicht, also es gibt deutlich weniger,
Masse Arme, Sterne, ähm also deutlich mehr Sterne in die Sonne, das heißt, je schwerer der Stern ist, desto schneller verbrennt er eigentlich auch sein Brennmaterial,
nach dem Motto live heit in dir so ein bisschen,
heißt, die Sterne sind eigentlich stabil, nicht nur wegen dieser Gravitationskraft, die nach innen wirkt, sondern auch gleichzeitig, weil's einen Strahlungsdruck gibt, der nach außen arbeitet.
Strahlungsdrück war da quasi aufrechterhalten durch die Kernfusion.
Das heißt irgendwann, wenn diese Kernphysio nicht mehr stattfinden kann, wer quasi keinen Wasserstoff mehr haben, dann werden sukzessiv andere Elemente durchgebrannt und das kann man quasi tatsächlich durchrechnen, zu welchem Zeitpunkt man dann quasi mit welchem Brennvorgang,
startet und wie lange der dann dauert und je nachdem wann man bestimmte Ausgangsmasse hat, sagen wir mal zwanzig Sonnenmassen, dann ist quasi der Punkt, an dem man,
Ähm das letzte Mal brennt, ist, wenn man Silizium brennt und durch Siliziumbrennen entsteht Eisen. Und Eisen,
Ist tatsächlich das Element, das am stabilsten ist in der Hinsicht, dass die,
Bindungsenergie, also die Energie, die zwei Nukleon zusammenhält, am größten ist.
Durch Kernfusionen kann man da keine Energie mehr weitergewinnen, wenn man quasi zu höheren Elementen gehen würde. Also bezeichnet das auch als Sternnasche. Also es ist so quasi das, was übrig bleibt, was am stabilsten ist.
Das ist der Grund, warum normale Sonnen nicht mehr als Eisen produzieren können.
Genau, also im normalen Fall sitzt man dann da mit einem Eisenkern. Das ist aber nur im Inneren der Fall und dann hat man da so einen riesen Eisenkern,
an sich eine super Masse hat ungefähr die Masse der Sonne, bisschen schwerer. Das heißt, der wird die äußeren Schichten alle anziehen und die fallen dann quasi nach innen aufgrund der Gravitation dieses inneren Eisenkerns. Und.
Wenn man Masse von weiter außen nach weiter innen bewegt, dann erhöht man quasi die Dichte, das erhöht die Temperaturen und dann setzt man,
kernphysikalische Prozesse in Kraft, die quasi die Atomkerne aufbrechen. Da macht man Protonen und Neutonnen draus,
Gibt's auch noch Elektronen und dann fängt man die Elektronen an den Proton ein und macht Neutonnen aus.
Das heißt, unter so extrem hohen Dichten, die wir in der Erde sehr, sehr schwierig herstellen können. Teilweise geht es in Teilchen und Beschleunigern, wo man Atomkerne aufeinander fliegen lässt und dann schaut, was dann wohl rauskommt. Aber im Prinzip, in jedem Stern, der so eine Masse hat,
sind das die Vorgänge und das kann man tatsächlich theoretisch quasi sich durchdenken.
Diesen Prozess, wo man dann eben viele Neutonnen erstellt, wird quasi so was wie was nennen wir in einem Protonetronenstern hergestellt?
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man dann angefangen hat, viele Neutronen herzustellen werden gleichzeitig auch noch viele Neutrinos produziert. Es ist quasi der Erhaltungssatz in der Kernphysik, die wir da haben.
Während diese äußeren Schichten nach innen fallen.
Arbeiten die Neutrinos nach außen und sorgen im Prinzip dafür, dass diese nach innenfallenden Schichten wenn sie dann denen diesen Eisenkern treffen und dann tatsächlich auch wieder nach außen aufgeblasen werden. Und das ist eigentlich der Prozess, den wir als Supernover bezeichnen. Das heißt,
haben sich dieses Gesamtkonzept, wie das alles insgesamt funktioniert, tatsächlich theoretisch hergeleitet mit den einzelnen Schritten, die ich gerade erwähnt habe und was dann übrig blieb nach dieser Supernuar, ist ein Neutonnenstern.
Das haben sie sich dann mal so am Nachmittag zusammengedacht.
Also.
Und dann irgendwie einen Paper äh veröffentlicht und andere haben sich das so angeschaut und so ja vielleicht.
Das klingt schon so ein bisschen abstrus, aber im Prinzip ist das genauso diese Vorhergehensweise. Man man hat eine bestimmte Menge an Annahmen,
Sagen wir mal physikalisch Gesetze und die Konzepte der Kernphysik, die waren schon deutlich besser verstanden, also ich würde sagen, die theoretische Astrophysik-Teil.
Man musste bis dahin auch, wie die Sonnenenergie produziert, das heißt, diese ganzen Kern äh Fusions und Spaltungsprozesse, die waren schon bekannt. Darauf konnte man natürlich dann aufbauen. Das ist nicht so, dass sie von einem Tag auf den anderen sich das alles beschäftigen.
Gleichzeitig wusste man auch schon relativ viel über so Sterne an sich, weil einfach Sterne schon sehr lange beobachtet werden. Das heißt, also das Konzept einer Supernova hatte man schon beobachtet. Dafür gab's Aufzeichnungen.
Haben schon sehr, sehr viel länger, aber man konnte da ungefähr auch ausrechnen, wie viel Energie dabei frei wurde,
Und so dieses Gesamtkonzept, dass man quasi dann diese Gravitationsenergie von diesem Stern umwandelt in die Supernova Energie und das, was noch sonst übrig bleibt, in Neutrinos.
Das konnte man dann schon tatsächlich auch irgendwie argumentieren. Aber bis zu dem Zeitpunkt war diese Vorhersage eines Notronensterns immer noch eine theoretische Vorhersage.
Noch mal eine Nachfrage. Diese äh Umwandlung in äh in Neutronen äh die da stattfindet,
nochmal genauer anschauen. Ich meine zu diesem Zeitpunkt wusste man ja noch gar nicht, woraus Neutronen das Neutronen überhaupt aus etwas anderem bestehen, dass also quasi dadrunter nochmal so eine Teilchenwelt, der äh der Quarks ähm eine Rolle spielt, vielleicht für die Betrachtung dann auch nicht relevant gewesen, hat ja auch
auch so funktioniert mit der Vorhersage in gewisser Hinsicht. Aber bestimmte Dinge wusste man jetzt nicht.
Was ist jetzt der Prozess, der dazu führt, dass da auf einmal so viele Neuronen entstehen und woraus entstehen die genau?
Also man nennt es das Konzept heißt Fotodesintegration. Also im Prinzip, wenn man diesen Eisenkern hat und den zusammendrückt, dann werden die Dichten mit den einzelnen Eisenattomen so groß, dass sie Eisenatome,
enger und enger sich zusammen bewegen. Okay? Das erhöht die Temperatur extrem.
Heißt das, die was heißt die also dass die Kerne einander näher.
Genau, die Kerne bewegen sich quasi also an sich Atome ähm also wir haben einen Atomkern mit Proton, wir haben Elektronen außen rum,
an sich.
Mögen die äußeren Elektroden jetzt nicht unbedingt dem Atomkern an sich nahe kommen, okay? Die sind eingestoßen die sich ab. Ähm wenn aber die Dichte so hoch wird, dass quasi die Teilchen,
nicht anders können als zusammengepresst zu werden, dann werden quasi die Elektronen von den Atomkernen gelöst, das heißt wir haben freie Elektronen und zusätzlich,
wird das Ganze deutlich heißer. Die Umwandlung sorgt dafür, dass wir Photonen hauptsächlich ähm Röntgenfotonen produzieren, die wiederum dafür sorgen.
Dass die Elektronen fliehen sozusagen, das ist die Umwandlung.
Also wir wir machen quasi im Prinzip viele freie Elektronen, die dann wiederum eingefangen werden können von Proton.
Also das ist quasi ein Elektronen und ein Proton, produziert ein Neuton und ein Elektroneutrino.
Und dann haben wir quasi sehr viele Neutronen.
Also ungefähr also im Inneren des neuen Tronstands gehen wir davon aus, dass ungefähr so 95 Prozent aller Teilchen Neutronen sind.
Fünfundneunzig. Okay.
Rest sind Protonen und noch ein Teil Elektronen und unter Umständen auch ein paar andere Teilchen von deren Existenz wir nicht so richtig wissen, ob sie denn existieren oder nicht? Ähm.
Und ganz viel Neutrinus.
Ganz viel Notinus. Und das ist eine der wenigen physikalischen Systeme, wo wir tatsächlich wissen, dass Neutrinus wirklich auch mit der Materie interagieren und eine Rolle spielen, weil normalerweise tun sie das eben nicht, genau.
Tun sie das ja eben nicht. Genau, das fragt ihr mich jetzt gerade, wodurch äh dieser dieser extreme Druck durch Neutrinus entstehen kann, wenn Neutrius eigentlich normalerweise so durchs All fliegen und sich für überhaupt.
Die Materie so, so, so extrem dicht ist.
Da ist dann einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit der Interaktion so hoch, dass sie dann eben auch wirklich stattfindet
Okay, alles klar. Das äh ist nachvollziehbar. Gut, also das war jetzt quasi von Bade und Zwicki das äh theoretische äh Gerüst. Sie haben sich so äh mal auf Nachmittag hingesetzt, haben wir alles zusammengerechnet und äh so aufm
Block irgendwie ausgerechnet, müsste es äh eigentlich geben.
Müsste es eigentlich geben.
Aber leuchtet nicht, ist extrem klein,
Ja? Wir reden ja dann auch wirklich von einer extremen Verkleinerung dieser gesamten Masse, dadurch, dass diese Dichte so hoch ist.
Genau, also der Neutonstadt hat ungefähr so zehn bis 12 Kilometer Radius, also so ein bisschen eine größere Stadt.
Also sozusagen nix.
Ungefähr ein bis zweimal die Sonne. Ja, also in astronomischen Größen ist zwölf Kilometer Radius nix. Das stimmt.
Hat man schon äh Probleme, das auf dem Mond zu erkennen.
Okay und dann ähm liegt das ja erstmal rum und ist erstmal so eine Behauptung, ne? So bis ähm mit Anschein war's ja auch nicht anders. Er hat ja auch gesagt so ja äh ist alles anders, als ihr euch das denkt
und alle so ja meinetwegen aber komm nicht so spät nach Hause bis dann halt wirklich experimentell
äh eine Vorhersage von ihm auch überprüft werden kann. Wann war's denn dann so weit, dass man jetzt auch das Gefühl hatte, da ist was dran.
Also du hast eben gesagt, dass Neutronensterne,
nicht leuchten und sie tun das nicht in dem Sinne wie die Sonne leuchtet, also wir haben kein Brennmaterial mehr, das heißt an sich, wir können keine Kernfusion mehr herstellen, das heißt,
Photonen, die wir so von der Sonne sehen und von anderen Stellen, die existieren tatsächlich nicht. Allerdings sind,
Metronensteine nicht tot in der Hinsicht, dass sie keinerlei Strahlung mehr aussenden. Also wir haben zwar keine Kernfunktion mehr, aber die sind tatsächlich sichtbar über einen großen Teil des elektromagnetischen Spektrums.
Und entdeckt wurden sie 1967 von Justin Bale Bernell, die damals ähm Doktorandin in Cambridge war,
maßgeblich am Aufbau eines Radioteleskops beteiligt war. Also Neutonnensterne wurden tatsächlich das erste Mal im Radiowellenlängenbereich, das sowieso von uns an unserer Kommunikation her kennen oder unser Mikrowelle.
Und das Gute ist, dass in dem Frequenzbereich die Atmosphäre tatsächlich durchlässig ist für diese Strahlung. Das heißt, wir müssen nicht in Weltraum gehen und einen äh einen Weltraum Teleskop bauen, um tatsächlich Radiowellen.
Und unsere außerirdischen Freunde können in der Zukunft sich alle unsere Fernsehserien anschauen, die wir so ausgestrahlt haben.
Unter Umständen. Ja ähm also das Radio Teleskop damals heute gibt's diverse,
Bauweisen Ferrari Teleskope, aber das Radio Teleskop damals da ungefähr aus wie viele Wäschen die nebeneinander aufgestellt waren.
Und die wurden damals nicht mit Computern ausgelesen, sondern mit Messschreibern. Das ist ungefähr so so ein so ein Stift, der sich quasi bewegt,
Blatt Papier ähm Millimeter Papier, damit man quasi die Ausschreitung des des Messschreibers sieht ähm und sie hat quasi per Hand meterweise von diesen,
Messschreiberpapieren ausgewertet und hat gesehen, dass in diesem Signal, also normalerweise ist das halt so ein bisschen fluktuierend um um eine Linie rum.
Gesehen, dass da tatsächlich irgendwann regelmäßige Einbuchungen drin sind und zwar im Abstand von ungefähr 1,3 Sekunden. Also sie hat quasi periodisches Signal entdeckt.
In einem und hat dann quasi ähm nachgeschaut, ob das tatsächlich auch in anderen Messdaten auch drin war und das war tatsächlich der Fall.
Also war das eine Signalspitze, dass er mehr Signal war oder weniger.
Bisschen drauf an, wie rum man das Messschreiberpapier benutzt. Also im Prinzip ist es also eine Einkerbung ähm beziehungsweise wenn man's andersrum sieht.
Also heißt es weniger Strahlung in dem Bereich oder mehr? Mehr, okay.
Man sieht mehr. Also es kommt aber drauf an, wie das wie der Messschreiber quasi das das ausmisst. Aber man hat quasi eine zusätzliche ähm Radioquelle, die zusätzlichen ähm die zusätzlich Radiostrahlung produziert.
Man muss dazu sagen, heute würde man das wohl nicht mehr erkennen, weil jeder Telefonmast die produzieren alle auch Radiostrahlung, das heißt, es ist sehr, sehr schwierig.
Wäre so hoch.
Genau ähm diese Signale tatsächlich dann auch auszulesen.
Es muss ja eine Höllenarbeit gewesen sein für sie äh von diesen ganzen Papierstreifen dann quasi so die Daten, ich meine, wie viel Daten musst du denn da äh also mit welchem Abstand waren denn diese Auskerbungen, dass man sie überhaupt als wahrnehmen konnte?
Also 1,3 Sekunden, das ist schon relativ kurz.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also ich glaube, dass das Problem war nicht so, also wenn man dann weiß, also man musste quasi, also das war das erste Mal, dass man irgendwas beobachtet hat und im Prinzip, wenn man irgendwas Neues findet, muss man immer erst die anderen Leute auch überzeugen, dass das tatsächlich auch ein reales.
Okay, aber das war ja dann auf dem Papier schon im Prinzip sichtbar. Ja. So.
Aber es hätte ja auch tatsächlich, also es gab damals schon auch Radio Radios, das hätte im Prinzip auch noch, also wir nennen das RFI Radio Frequency Interference, also diese Streustrahlung, es im Prinzip sein können.
Nachdem man dann da irgendwie aber also das Signal auch in in späteren oder früheren Aufzeichnungen gefunden hat, war's dann schon irgendwie klar, dass das dann tatsächlich irgendwie auch
vom Himmel kommen musste und so ähm scherzhaft wurde das äh Signal ursprünglich oder die die Quelle des Signals, wo du ursprünglich LG M-Bonn getauft, was für Little Green Men stand. Ähm weil man eben am Anfang nicht wusste genau, was denn tatsächlich der.
Weil alles, was so regelmäßig ist, irgendwie nicht so richtig zum Bild der Natur passte.
Genau oder? Also beziehungsweise man hatte das halt bis dahin einfach nicht entdeckt. Wenn man nicht genau weiß, was das ist, wenn man das erste Mal irgendwas sieht, dann muss man sich immer irgendwie da tatsächlich auch davon überzeugen, dass das wirklich ein reales Signal ist, nicht durch irgendwas anders ähm erstellt wird. Und.
Das Paper wurde dann ein Jahr später veröffentlicht und,
Ja, es gibt da so eine also ich würde sagen, keine kleinen. Es ist eine ziemlich große Kontroverse in unserem Fachbereich, dass,
Bei Banell, die eigentlich die die tatsächlich dann das Signal auch entdeckt hat, nicht mit ihrem Doktorvater,
und jemand anderem in der Arbeitsgruppe tatsächlich auch den Nobelpreis dafür bekommen hat, sondern der ging an ihren Betreuer. Ähm obwohl quasi sie im Prinzip,
Signal als Allererste entdeckt hat.
Immer wieder die gleiche Geschichte. Mhm.
Also die eine der wenigen Frauen, die tatsächlich auch dort gearbeitet haben und war eben Doktorandin.
Inwiefern wusste man denn jetzt, also was ist denn jetzt sozusagen der Schluss? Äh ich meine, jetzt habe ich da eine 1,3 Sekunden, eine Quelle, da äh sagt man ja nicht gleich hurra neuronenstern, sondern das kann ja irgendwas sein.
Es wurde da also klar, die haben Leute haben sich dann natürlich darüber unterhalten und das die Sache ist, dass man quasi sagen konnte, dass das von einem relativ engen Bereich vom Himmel kommt.
Das heißt, man kann quasi dann, wenn man das Radio Teleskop, sagen wir mal, in die andere Richtung oder weg von der bestimmten Position bewegt, dann sieht man das Signal eben nicht mehr.
Das heißt, man konnte dann tatsächlich auch vorhersagen.
Die Wäscheleine in die andere Richtung aufgehäng.
Nicht ganz, also man kann das tatsächlich ein bisschen richten, je nachdem wie man dann die die Daten ausliest. Ähm dann konnte man aber schon vorhersagen, dass das von einem relativ kompakten Teil des Himmels kommen muss.
Es gibt jetzt nicht so viele kompakte Objekte. Schwarze Löcher an sich strahlen nicht, weil die sind schwarz.
Die war zu dem Zeitpunkt theoretisch auch schon vorhergesagt.
Schwarze Löcher wurden ähm schon vorhergesagt, kurz nach dem Einstein quasi die die ähm einsteinschen Feldgleichung aufgeschrieben habe. Aber es war dann schon relativ zügig klar, dass das im Prinzip ein Neuronenstern oder ein weißer Zwerg sein muss.
Weißer Zwerg ist ein kompaktes Objekt, das ist ungefähr so groß wie die Erde und wiegt ungefähr einmal so viel wie die Sonne,
Es wurde auch theoretisch vorhergesagt, dass es ein anderes Endprodukt im Prinzip ähm der Sternentstehung.
Aber die Frequenzen, also diese 1,3 Sekunden,
Die haben eher auf einen Neutronensternen Ursprung hingewiesen. Und zusätzlich kam dann noch, dass man im Prinzip zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Theoretisch mehr Arbeit investiert hat, um diese Objekte, die tatsächlich vorher ungefähr dreißig,
30 Jahre vorhergesagt wurde, auch theoretisch besser zu verstehen. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt haben Leute sich mit einem Thema beschäftigt, also neutralen Stern.
Den man eigentlich noch nicht wusste, ob's überhaupt existiert, aber haben theoretisch quasi versucht zu verstehen, was für Eigenschaften diese Sterne denn tatsächlich hätten.
Aber die Einengung auf könnte ein Neuronenstern sein, ergab sich jetzt zunächst einmal eher erstmal aus der Frequenz als solcher,
gemessen wurde und der Tatsache, dass so, wie man's gemessen hat, sagen könnte, okay, muss ein kompaktes Ding sein und wir haben jetzt auch in unserer ganzen theoretischen Vorhersage nicht so viele kompakte Dinge.
Die auch in diesem Frequenzbereich irgendwas abstrahlen. Aber zu diesem Pettern als solchen gab's in dem Sinne noch überhaupt gar keine
Theorie vorher, worauf das hinweisen könnte oder ist es auch ein Indiz gewesen schon?
Wir wissen oder wir denken heute, dass dieses regelmäßige radiosignal.
Außen Zusammenspiel von zwei verschiedenen Sachen hergestellt wird und zwar einmal ist es die extrem schnelle Rotation dieser Neutonnensterne und dann, dass sie ein großes Magnetfeld haben.
Die beiden Sachen unter Umständen der Fall sind, das hatte man vorher auch schon theoretisch vorhergesagt. Im Prinzip kann man sich das so ein bisschen ableiten aus relativ einfachen Erhaltungssätzen. Also man wusste,
schon das Sterne, normale Sterne, wie die Sonne oder mastreiche Sterne wie die Sonne rotieren. Also nicht völlig still, sondern das Plasma, das den sich in diesen Stern befindet, das rotiert.
Rotiert ja alles.
Genau, also je nachdem, das ist irgendwie.
Mehr, manches weniger.
Beinhaltet dann quasi ursprünglich die Rotation der Molekülröcke, aus denen der Stern entstanden ist und dann gibt's noch Konfektion,
Auf kleinere Skalen, aber auf jeden Fall ist das nicht statisch. Das sitzt nicht da still. Das rotiert auf der Sternskala relativ lange, aber wenn man sich so diesen, nennen wir's mal, Piroteneffekt anguckt, also das beruht auf der Erhaltung des DrehImpulses, wenn man was Großes hat, was langsam rotiert,
Man macht quasi was sehr Kleines draus, dann muss das deutlich schneller rotieren.
Oder auch so dieses Spielplatzerlebnis, wenn man erstmal auf diesem.
Genau.
Dingen sich einmal in die Mitte begibt und dann hui,
Das heißt, allein dadurch, dass der Notrodenstern so kompakt zusammengedrückt wird, aber die Rotationsenergie in dem Sinne erhalten bleibt, führt es zwangsläufig zu einem wirren Kreisel.
Konnte man schon sagen, dass diese Tronscheide, wenn sie denn dann existieren, auf jeden Fall schnell rotieren müssen.
Und schnell ist.
Also es kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, welche Art man von Matronen stellt man sich an, guckt, aber die Rotationsperioden sind alles so von ungefähr Millisekunden bis zu ungefähr zehn Sekunden. Also bisschen so wie so eine gute Küchenmaschine.
Millisekunden. Einmal ganz rum, Millisek.
Millisekunden, ja. Ja, eine Millisekunde.
Okay. Das äh.
Ich glaube, der schnellste Neuronenstein, den wir haben, der rotiert so mit siebenhundertsechzehn, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, Herz. Das ist schon ordentlich.
Mhm. Gut, aber die Strahlung, die davon ausgeht, dass ja sozusagen immer noch dieser dieser Neutrino äh Effekt oder ist das nur beim Zusammenfallen? Also was macht die Strahlung dann aus?
Neuronsterne an sich wenn sie geboren werden, sind sie relativ heiß, also sie haben ungefähr so zehn hoch,
elf Kelvin, das ist schon ordentlich heiß, aber innerhalb von sehr kurzer Zeit aufgrund dieses Neutrineverlustes, die einen großen Teil dieser Energie ähm wegtragen, kühlen die relativ zügig zu ungefähr so was wie zehn hoch neun Kelvin und.
Ungefähr nach sagen wir mal 1000 bis zehntausend Jahren ähm,
kühlt der Stern nicht mehr durch Neutrinus, sondern durch Photon. Okay. Diese Neutrinus von dem Neutronstern an sich sehen wir nicht. Also wir haben.
Genau. Wir haben tatsächlich ähm ein paar Neutrinos von der Supernova in von neunzehnhundertsiebenundachtzig. Also das heißt, dieser Entstehungsprozess, den glauben wir besser zu verstehen, aber die Neutrinus vom Neutronenstein an sich, die sehen wir nicht.
Ähm jetzt ist die Frage, was produziert die Radierstrahlung? Und da spielt in die Rotationen der Hinsicht eine Rolle, dass das Magnetfeld des Sterns, das auch sehr stark ist.
Nicht ganz miteinander in die gleiche Richtung zeigen, also das Neutronenstern-Magnetfeld, das sieht oder wir glauben, das hat ähm,
ähnliche Struktur wie von so einem Starkmagneten auf der Erde. Also wir haben einen Nordpol und einen Südpol und dann haben wir diese schönen Magnetfeldlinien, die so ein bisschen gebogen sind.
Und die Achse von diesem Magnetfeld, die zeigt in eine andere Richtung, wie die Rotationsachse. Man kann sich das jetzt so ein bisschen vorstellen, dass da,
Teilchen von der Oberfläche teilweise abgerissen werden, aufgrund dieser hohen Magnetfelder und die Teilchen werden beschleunigt entlang der Magnetfeldlinien.
Beschleunigte Teilchen sorgen immer dafür, dass Strahlung ausgesendet wird.
Und man sollte dazu sagen, wir wissen immer noch nicht genau, obwohl wir diese Dinger seit 55 Jahren beobachten wie denn genau die Radiostrahlung tatsächlich funktioniert, aber die Idee ist, dass quasi entlang der Magnetfeldachse,
Strahlung oder Teichen beschleunigt werden, die produzieren Radiostrahlung und wenn sich der Nutronststellen um die Rotationsachse dreht, dann bewegt sich quasi dieser Kegel,
Strahlung um den Stern. Man kann sich das so ein bisschen vorstellen wie ein Leuchtturm.
Also anstelle der der Lampe haben wir quasi unseren Radiostrahl und das geht normalerweise in beide Richtungen, also vom Nord- und Südpol weg und je nachdem, wenn man Glück hat und quasi in diesem Kegel sitzt und da über einen hinwegfegt, dann sieht man dieses periodische Signal.
So denken wir, dass dieses Zusammenspiel, das zwischen der Rotation und dem Magnetfeld tatsächlich auch dann ähm genau.
Diesen repetiven äh führt.
Extrem regelmäßigen, muss man dazu sagen.
Also nochmal die die Strahlung
dauerhafte Strahlung entsteht durch diesen permanenten Druck, der in diesem neuronenstern nach wie vor herrscht, wo die Elektroden irgendwie so ihre Schwierigkeiten haben äh noch so ihren Platz äh zu finden, wären dann als Photonen
abgestrahlt, aber der starke Magnetismus, der Neutronensterne kanalisiert diese Strahlung.
Noch ein bisschen anders, also die,
Die photonische Strahlung, die ich eben erwähnt habe, die geht eigentlich von der Oberfläche weg. Und die Oberflächenstrahlung von diesem von diesem Neutronenstern ähm,
Die sieht man nicht im ähm Radiobereich. Also das ist tatsächlich so, dass es da unterschiedliche Teile gibt, die man mit verschiedenen Teleskopen beobachten kann in unterschiedlichen Teilen des Elektromagnetischen Spektrums. Und das, was man quasi,
als Radiostrahlung sieht, das wird im Prinzip ähm,
Das entsteht im Prinzip durch die Umwandlung der Rotationsenergie des Neutonterns. Also es hat nix mit den Photonen tatsächlich, die entstehen aufgrund von der bestimmten Temperatur des Tanz, sondern man extrahiert in gewisser Weise.
Rotationsenergie uns erzählen.
Energie des Sterns, genau.
Das passiert eben dadurch, dass wenn wir nennen das eine bestimmte Kaskade, also so eine so eine Lawine an Teilchen entsteht in den äußeren Schichten, dieser Magnetopsphäre des Neutronensterns, Hotelchen beschleunigt werden. Und im Prinzip.
Sorgt das dann dafür, dass diese Radiostrahlung in einer bestimmten Richtung ausgesendet wird und wir sehen dann die zusätzlich. Und das ist quasi,
Dieser Leuchtturmeffekt, der dazu geführt hat, dass dieses Radiosignal 1967 und mittlerweile für ungefähr 3000 andere Neuronensterne tatsächlich auch beobachtet werden kann.
Das heißt, ihre,
Messung, die gemacht hat, war im Prinzip von einem neuronen Stern, bei dem eben jetzt dieses Spiel aus Rotationsachse versus Magnetachse
dazu geführt hat, dass quasi die Erde,
immer alle 1,3 Sekunden in diesem in Anführungsstrichen Lichtstrahl äh von Radiowellen kurz auftauchte.
So über die Erde so rüber äh fegte und das äh führte dann eben zu diesem Ausschlag auf dem Papier.
Genau.
Und das war ja dann auch das ist ja dann auch super stabil und bleibt quasi so nicht in alle Ewigkeit, aber für unsere Zeiten schon in alle Ewigkeiten erstmal konnte.
Genau, also diese diese Idee, dass das also da man muss sich das wirklich nochmal so ein bisschen vor Augen führen, weil also diese Sterne rotieren mit Millisekunden,
Perioden haben aber ungefähr so viel Masse wie die Sonne, also es steckt Unmengen an Energien drin, okay? Und deshalb ist es relativ schwierig so einen Stern irgendwie von heute auf morgen abzubremsen. Das heißt,
das hat so viel so viel Trägheitsmoment, dass das einfach für eine sehr lange Zeit weiter rotiert und.
Die Tatsache, dass es aber Magnetfeld hat und notiert, sorgt im Prinzip dafür, dass es über Zeit, weil wir ja auch, wie gesagt,
Energie irgendwie extrahieren über dieses über diese Radiostrahlung im Prinzip, dass das tatsächlich auch langsamer wird. Das bräuchte wirklich Millionen von Jahren bis so notrohenstand tatsächlich aufhört, sich zu bewegen. Also wir benutzen das auch wirklich als,
als quasi,
Als Hilfestellung, um zu verstehen, was denn in dem Stern tatsächlich passiert. Also wir nennen das ähm Radio Paulser Timing, also wir wir timen, also wir stoppen tatsächlich ähm diese Radiopulse, um zu verstehen.
Die dann teilweise doch nicht immer hundertprozentig regelmäßig ähm auf der Erde auftauchen, um zu verstehen, was denn tatsächlich auch da passiert. Also ein Teil dieser vor allem die ähm die,
Die eben ähm,
Millisekundenbereich, Radiostrahlung aussenden, die sind extrem stabil und wir benutzen die da teilweise tatsächlich, um ähm.
Andere Effekte im Universum besser zu überstehen können. Also zum Beispiel für diese millisecond, wenn ihr die Millisecond Powers,
Die sind so stabil, dass man quasi, wenn man mehrere hat, versuchen könnte, auf der aufgrund der,
Änderung dieser Ankunftszeiten, diese einzelnen Pulse, dass man da versuchen könnte.
Änderung in der Raumzeit zu messen. Also ähm wir können vielleicht gleich noch ein bisschen über Gravitationswellen reden, aber dieses Konzept des ähm,
wenn denn das Palzer Timing a Ray also wir haben quasi eine Aufreihung verschiedener Pulsare ähm,
wenn die Raumzeit sich,
im Verhältnis von uns zu dem jeweiligen Milisecond Polster. Verändert kann man tatsächlich, so genau sind diese Dinger vorhersagen, ob dann deine Gravitationswelle durchgegangen ist.
Das ist aber auch noch Theorie.
Bis jetzt noch. Also das ist nicht so, dass es wahrscheinlich einzelne Signale gibt, sondern in den Bereichen, wo diese Polstertiming-Arace tatsächlich sensitiv sind. Das ist ungefähr im im Nano Herzbereich. Eine der großen Kollaborationen heißt Nanograph in Nordamerika.
Aus dem schokastischen Hintergrund.
Entdecken können. Das heißt, es sind viele einzelne Signale übereinander gelegt. Man hat quasi so ein so ein rauschen, dass man durch diese Neutonsterne entdecken können möchte. Und.
Das sagt uns in gewisser Weise, wie genau diese Dinger sind. Also so ein großer Teil der, die wir in diesem Frequenzbereich sehen, die sind tatsächlich genauer als jeder Atomor auf der Erde.
Es hast du jetzt einen Begriff äh zwischendurch fallen lassen, den man jetzt vielleicht nochmal,
genau äh in den Mittelpunkt stellen müssen, weil das, was ja hier eigentlich,
von entdeckt wurde war ein also ein
Neutronenstern, der eben genau dieses pulsierende Element hat, weil eben, wie schon beschrieben, Rotationsachse, Magnet äh Achse et cetera so zusammen kam und dann eben die relative Stellung zur Erde, dass man eben genau diesen Effekt hat,
Theoretisch auch sein, dass diese beiden Achsen irgendwie was sie nicht,
identisch sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob das äh überhaupt äh realistisch ist so, dann dann würde es ja diesen Effekt so äh gar nicht geben. Da hat man einfach, hätte man ja entweder eine permanente Strahlenquelle oder gar keine.
So was ist aber noch gar nicht gefunden worden.
Das ist wirklich das ist wie gesagt genau das Problem, das heißt man sieht Neutonsterne ist im großen Teil nur dann, wenn man im Radiobereich, also man sieht die mit, wir können gleich nochmal vielleicht über die anderen Wellenlängen ein bisschen reden ähm im Radiobereich sieht man die wirklich nur, wenn man in diesen Kegel guckt. Das heißt, sagen wir mal,
Man guckt auf den Äquator und der Kegel geht zum Nord-oder Südpol hin, dann sieht man den nicht. Das heißt wirklich ein Großteil der Naturnsteine, die wir bei uns in der Umgebung haben, in der unserer äh Milchstraße
Die sehen wir tatsächlich nicht. Also man geht davon aus, dass die Anzahl der Naturnsterne in der Milchstraße so um die zehn hoch 8 bis zehn hoch 9 sind.
Also ungefähr so eine Milliarde. Die sehen aber ungefähr nur dreitausend. Also ein Großteil,
Das gehört auch dazu, dass wenn die weit weg sind, dann ist es natürlich deutlich schwieriger die zu sehen oder wenn sie hinter einer großen,
Gas und Staubwolke sich befinden, dann sehen wir die Radiostrahlung auch sehr schwierig, weil die da eben teilweise nicht durchgehen kann. Ähm.
Aber im Prinzip sind da viele neue Tronsteine, die wir einfach nicht sehen. Und ein großer Teil,
liegt daran, dass sie eben quasi nicht in unsere Richtung zeigen. Das heißt, wenn wir an einem anderen Ort in der Mähstraße wären, dann könnten wir unter Umständen diese Sterne sehen. Wenn wir auf der Erde an sich sind, ähm dann sind wir.
Haben wir Pech gehabt und.
Und diese Pulsare sind,
jetzt einfach extrem praktisch. Also abgesehen davon, dass er sozusagen klares Indiz ist,
okay, das passt jetzt hier zu unseren Modellen,
wahrscheinlich ein Neurodenstern. Jetzt haben wir quasi mal eine Messung gemacht, um mal experimentell wirklich nachweisen können, was ja bis dahin eigentlich nur theoretisch vorhergesagt äh wurde und ich weiß nicht, war man sich dann auch schnell sicher?
Ja also ich würde sagen.
Ja, also von dem Interpretationsraum her, da war nicht mehr so viel offen und nachdem man irgendwie dann weiß, wie man nach diesen Dingern sucht, das ist auch so eine Sache, wenn man weiß, wonach man schauen muss,
dann findet man auf einmal dann auch mehr. Und kurz nachdem dann dieses Signal entdeckt wurde ähm hat man dann auch noch weitere dieser Signale tatsächlich dann auch von anderen Orten,
um uns rum entdeckt und konnte die dann auch deutlich mh besser zuordnen. Also zwei dieser ähm,
Neutonnensterne, die mittlerweile auch wirklich so ziemlich die best untersuchtesten Objekte sind, ist einmal der Notronnenstern im Krebsnebel, den also der Krebspulver,
dann der Notrodenstern, den wir als Wählerpulver bezeichnen,
Also man man wusste quasi dann auch noch, wo man wo man schauen muss, weil wenn man zum Beispiel irgendwo weiß, dass ein Supernova, wie zum Beispiel im Falle des Krebsnebels, tatsächlich auch stattgefunden hat, dann kann man dann auch mal gucken, ob man in der Richtung dann auch was findet.
Hat man dann tatsächlich auch geschafft.
Okay. Also man muss ja auch lange nicht, was ist eigentlich seit Krebsnebel, so was ist sozusagen das Ding? Dann hat man irgendwann festgestellt, so hm passt eigentlich super zu der Vorhersage.
Äh Supernova, also von Sternenexplosion. Das sind halt so die Überbleibsel. Da war doch was. Ach ja, genau, da bleibt ja ein Neutonstern äh vielleicht übrig, wenn es also alles die richtige Masse gehabt hat, ne
und wenn man dann reinhorcht so
mal da tatsächlich passt das hier wieder mit der Rotationsachse und jetzt haben wir auch hier unseren Pulser und diese Posare, da können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal ein bisschen drüber äh sprechen, überhaupt so über die ganze Multi-Messenger äh Dimension äh reden, aber das ist ja dann sozusagen auch
so eine dieser,
Sagt man so, Standardkerzen, ne, also dass man sozusagen so eine mal so eine so eine klare Definition hat von so einer,
Zeiteinheit, die bleibt auch irgendwie konstant und eben wenn sie sich dann eben ändert, dann weiß es wiederum auf
äh andere Dinge äh hin, was es auch immer dann in dem Moment ist. Jetzt möchte ich aber nochmal kurz bleiben wir ja sozusagen auch noch voll in dieser theoretischen Physik mit drin,
Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit so gehört so ja okay Magnetfelder und so.
Planeten haben ja nicht immer ein Magnetfeld so, aber offensichtlich haben die Neuronensterne immer eins. Äh warum?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Vielleicht sollte ich einmal kurz ausholen. Also normalerweise, wenn man äh wenn man jemanden ärgern möchte während eines wissenschaftlichen Vortrags und die Person sich mit irgendeinem Phänomen in der Astronomie beschäftigt und dann sagt,
Mit Magnetfall dann aus? Dann ist normalerweise niemand glücklich. Magnetfelder sind super schwierig
theoretisch zu beschreiben und es ist wirklich ein Phänomen auf größten Skalen, die wir wirklich sehr, sehr schlecht verstehen. Man sollte denken, dass wir das Magnetfeld der Erde zum Beispiel auf dem Planeten, auf dem wir leben, dessen,
Ursprung wird tatsächlich verstehen und das ist selbst auf der Skala nicht der Fall. Also es ist wirklich sehr schwer, sagen wir mal von First principles, also aufgrund von irgendwie
Standardprinzipien, damit tatsächlich von irgendwelchen physikalischen Gleichungen anfangen kann und dann tatsächlich mit dem Magnetfeld endet, dass wir tatsächlich beobachten, auch für unsere Erde.
Auf astronomischen Skalen und den astronomischen oder astrophysikalischen Phänomen spielen Magnetfeld aber oft eine sehr große Rolle.
Und was, was ich vorhin schon für die Rotation gesagt habe? Also diese Idee, dass ähm der also wir nennen das den Vorläuferstern, dass er bestimmte Eigenschaften hat und die sich dann in gewisser Weise auf den Naturnstein übertragen,
Das gilt auch für das Magnetfeld und zwar wir wissen, dass Sterne wie die Sonne oder auch massereiche Sterne,
Auch Magnetfelder haben, also da werden Teilchen beschleunigt. Wir sehen teilweise diese wunderschönen Bögen in der Sonne mit diversen Teleskopen. Das heißt, wir wissen auch, dass,
massereiche Sterne, Magnetfelder haben. Jetzt gibt's ähnlich wie für die Tränenpulverhaltung, also für die Rotation, gibt's auch einen Erhaltungssatz für magnetischen Fluss.
Und zwar der magnetische Fluss ähm bleibt erhalten und wenn wir jetzt den Querschnitt des Sterns für eine bestimmte Magnetverstärke,
stark komprimieren, dann muss das Magnetfeld,
an sich, weil der magische Fluss erhalten bleibt, deutlich höher werden. Das ist ähnlich wie vorhin mit der Rotation, wo der Dreh-Impuls erhalten bleibt. Und das gilt übrigens auch für weiße Zwerge.
Zwerge haben auch relativ starke Magnetfelder, aber deutlich dadurch, dass sie deutlich größer sind als,
als er Stadt, also ungefähr so groß wie die Erde, ist das Magnetfall von einem weißen Zwerg kleiner als das vom Latronenstern, weil der deutlich kleiner ist.
Also so diese Idee, dass es da tatsächlich Magnetfaller geben muss, die sehr stark sind, das kommt schon mal aufgrund der Tatsache, dass wir,
Magnetfelder auch in einem normalen Stern beobachten.
Magnetfeld sind ja immer ganz unabhängig davon, warum sie da sind, äh wenn sie da sind und sie sind oft da und wenn sie dann komprimiert werden, bleiben sie auch da und sind dann aber auch stark.
Und also das das Konzept dieses Magnetfelds.
Klar in so einem Stabmagneten, wenn wir einen Ferro, also das ist ein Ferromagonie, das heißt, das hat irgendwie ähm im Magneten an sich,
Bestimmte Orientierung in den Atomen, die mir dann
größer skalig ist, also sagen wir mal Fingergröße, Magnetfeld erstellen. Jetzt gibt's aber noch in dem neuronstern im Prinzip, wie man da das Magnetfeld erstellen kann, ähm eine andere Art, wie man sich das vorstellen kann und zwar jeder
ähm die sich immer mit den Maxvergleichungen beschäftigt habe. Also die Gleichung, die uns quasi erklären, wie ähm.
Elektromagnetische Wellen sich bewegen und wie die quasi erzeugt werden, das ist alles das gleiche Phänomen ist. Der weiß, dass im Prinzip, wenn man ein ähm wenn man ein,
Kreisstrom hat, also ein Strom, der im Kreis läuft, dann ist das Magnetfeld, was man dadurch sieht, ungefähr das eine Stabmagnetens. Also sagen wir mal, man sich das so vorstellt. Man hat ähm einen äh Kreisturm, der ihn durch den durch den,
Tisch vor einem fließt. Also das nennen wir mal das im Äquator. Dann wird das Magnetfeld.
Senkrechter zu sein, also es sieht ungefähr so aus, wie man den Stabmagnet auf den Tisch stellt.
Diese Art der Ströme, die existieren wahrscheinlich auch im Neutronenstern, das heißt was tatsächlich wirklich eine Rolle spielt, sind,
wie sich die Teilchen, die geladen sind, wirklich dann auch bewegen. Das heißt, wir haben unter Umständen eine eine Teilkomponente des Magnetfelds, die von diesem ursprünglichen Sternkollaps entsteht. Also wir nennen das auch fossil,
also das fossile Feld. Aber zusätzlich gibt's wahrscheinlich auch diese Art von Ströme, die meistens mit einem bestimmten Dynamo-Prozess in Verbindung gebracht werden, die dann tatsächlich auch,
so angeordnet sind, dass wir auf bestimmten größeren Skalen von der Stadt dann tatsächlich auch ein größeres, galliges Magnetfeld sehen.
Da bricht jetzt so ein bisschen diese Idee mit dem Stabmagneten, dass das auch für den neuronstein gilt, dass also dass das Magnetfeld so ähnlich aussieht, bricht ein bisschen zusammen, weil wir wissen mittlerweile, dass es.
Wahrscheinlich nur zu teilen so aussieht. Also wo man sehr, sehr weit weg vom Stern ist,
diese typischen Bögen haben, die wir auch bei einem dipolaren Magnet sehen. Wenn man aber wirklich näher an den Sternen geht, ähm wird's wahrscheinlich unter Umständen,
andere Strukturen geben, wo das Magnetfeld sich auf deutlich kleineren Skalen ansortiert. Ähm und das liegt eben daran, dass es da tatsächlich Zeichen gibt, die sich bewegen und dann bestimmte Magnetfeld
erstellen. Aber im Endeffekt liegt's wirklich tatsächlich daran, dass ich da geladene Teilchen, nämlich Elektronen in dem Stern befinden und sich die relativ,
in irgendeiner Weise bewegen, weil der Standort hier.
Das heißt da da sind einfach äh gigantische Strömer einfach am Werken und wo irgendwie elektrische Ströme, da sind auch die magnetischen Felder einfach nicht weit weg,
Selbst wenn jetzt äh dieser Urstern, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, relativ wenig Magnetfeld hätte gehabt hätte oder ich weiß nicht, gibt's Sterne auch ohne Magnetfeld? Kann man sich irgendwie.
Also soweit ich weiß, also ich würde sagen, jeder Stern hat ein Magnetfeld, aber in manchen Sternen ist das wahrscheinlich eher schwächer, also im normalen Stern kommt es auch darauf an
wie Teilchen sich da bewegen, weil das erzeugt dann auch wiederum das Magnetfeld und je nachdem wie tatsächlich die Bewegung dieser einzelnen Teilchen, also dieses Passmaß vonstatten,
auch unterschiedliche Magnetfelder haben. Aber ich weiß zum Beispiel jetzt nicht, was das niedrigste Magnetfeld eines Sterns ist, das wir bis jetzt gemessen haben.
Okay, also es könnte sein, dass fossile Komponente eine größere Rolle spielt oder es könnte sein, dass es irgendwie dieser ganze äh elektrische Fluss, der einfach zwangsläufig stattfindet in diesem ganzen Elektronengewirr.
Einfach in der Summe, also sozusagen Neutonstern ohne Magnetfeld gibt's nicht. Okay, gut, halten wir das mal fest.
Sagen wir mal so ähm das Magnetfeld wird sich verändern und es wird auch immer weniger werden. Also wenn man irgendwo eine Million Jahre lang oder,
zehn Millionen Jahre lang wartet, dann wird das Magnetfeld auch teilweise zerfallen, einfach nur, weil der Stern rotiert und dann eben zusätzlich irgendwie dem Ganzen schon Energie entziehen können, auch teilweise der magnetischen Energie.
Ähm das heißt, über sehr, sehr, sehr lange Zeit wird das Magnetfeld schwächer, ähm aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir,
haben, der gar kein Magnetfeld hat. Also je älter der Stern, desto schwächer das Magnetfeld,
Je jünger der Stirn, desto stärker das Magnetfeld.
Und wir benutzen das auch, um bestimmte Neutonnensterne, bestimmte Kategorien einzuteilen. Also ich habe vorhin gesagt, dass wir ungefähr so 3000 Neutonnenstände mittlerweile kennen. Diese 3000 Neutonnenstände sind nicht alle gleich.
Als Wissenschaftler versucht man dann, wenn man teilweise irgendwie so eine große Population vor sich hat und 3000 geht ungefähr gerade so, versucht man die teilweise dann so einzuteilen und zu sagen, okay, die haben ähnliche Eigenschaften.
Dann bilden die eine Gruppe und die haben andere ähnlichen Eigenschaften, dann bilden die eine Gruppe. Und das Magnetfeld ist eine dieser,
Achsen, wo wir quasi den Nordronster so ein bisschen auftragen können, um zu sagen, okay die Neuronenstände, die sich an einem Ende befinden, haben diese Eigenschaften und die Nordrodensteine, die sich am anderen Ende befinden, haben andere Eigenschaften.
Magnetfeld haben, die beobachten wir tatsächlich nicht durch diese Radiostrahlung, die ich vorher benannt habe, weil wir davon ausgehen, obwohl wir da also das ist was, das wissen wir tatsächlich auch nicht richtig
Dass wir davon ausgehen, dass das Neutronstein für diese sehr, sehr,
Magnetstarken ähm Felder,
die wirklich ein Magnetfeld haben, das nicht so richtig deepula aussieht, wie das, wie ich,
beschrieben habe, sondern dass da tatsächlich äh höhere Magnetpolmomente,
ähm eine Rolle spielen und das tatsächlich sehr, sehr, sehr turbulent aussieht, das Magnetfeld da. Und wozu das führt in diesen sogenannten Magnetan ist,
dass sie tatsächlich Ausbrüche durchgehen, also die sind.
Teilweise relativ ruhig und wenn man jetzt ein äh Röntgenteles benutzt und durch so einen während so eines solchen Ausbruchs auf den Neutronnenstern schaut,
Dann sieht man tatsächlich extrem viele Röntgenphotonen. Also das Magnetfeld in der Hinsicht sorgt dafür, dass ähm da was turbulent,
an der Oberfläche passiert, weil das Magnetfeld ist immer noch irgendwie im Nordonstein an sich verankert,
Magnet verdienen sind aber doch also die die entwickeln sich, die bewegen sich, die sind nicht so richtig stabil, vor allem wenn der Stern rotiert,
sorgen eben dafür, vor allem durch wir nennen es Rekollektion, also wenn zwei verschiedene Magnet verdienen, die sich quasi kreuzen, kostet es Energie, das heißt, die werden sich verbinden.
Und neu ausordnen und das sorgt im Prinzip dafür, dass wir Energie freisetzen. Und man sieht eben diese Freisetzung im Röntgenbereich.
Sehr viel mehr chaotisches äh.
Also.
Was nicht mehr so diese Regelmäßigkeit dieser Posare einfach hat.
Also man sieht das dann teilweise auch irgendwie von der Oberfläche, das heißt, man kann teilweise schon die Rotationsperiode irgendwie,
extrahieren, aber das ist deutlich virulenter und man sieht diese Röntgenstrahlen nicht immer in diesen Magnetan. Also die müssen quasi tatsächlich sich in so einem Ausbruch befinden, dass man dann auch,
diese speziellen Hochmagnetstarken, Nutronensterne dann tatsächlich auch beobachten kann.
Das ist dann sozusagen die Bezeichnung für diese Art. Und das sind dann eben nicht,
habe. Oder gibt's Überschneidungen, ne? Genau, so einfach.
Ich würde sagen, da gibt's über Überschneidung. Also ähm man.
Meine Eigenschaft, generell.
Genau, also wenn irgend so ein Sternen großes Magnetfeld hat, dann sind die halt meistens auch nicht nur im Radiobereich sichtbar, sondern auch im Röntgenbereich. Und von denen kennen wir tatsächlich nur so ein paar Dutzend. Also das ist deutlich weniger,
als das für die Hauptpopulation der Neutonsteine, die wir als Radioposare sehen, der Fall ist.
Ein bisschen dadrüber noch genauer wie man jetzt neu delegieren kann. So die
Urmethode haben wir jetzt gefunden, also die Polsare, wo es jetzt irgendwie relativ äh klar war, konnte man Radiowellen waren. Jetzt lernen wir schon, okay, Magnetare sind so diese total ausgeflippten,
roten Sterne, die irgendwie so ein mega chaotisches Magnet äh Feld verhalten haben, dass eben so diese regelmäßigen Ausbrüche oder regelmäßigen Ausstrahlungen,
so gar nicht mehr wahrnehmbar sind, sondern das kuliniert dann immer in irgendeinem Moment und dann ist es aber Röntgenstrahlung, die man im wesentlichen wahrnimmt, spricht, da braucht man Röntgenteles Gruppe äh,
dafür. Ähm dass es dann wahrscheinlich später irgendwann.
Genau, also nachdem man dann irgendwie so wusste, dass Posare und Neuronenscheine tatsächlich so existieren in den Sechzigern,
Ähm sagen wir mal ungefähr so zehn bis 20 Jahre später hat man dann auch vorher gesagt im Prinzip so die Energien, die da
involviert sind, also weil man weiß ungefähr von den Posaren, was für eine Art von Magnetverstärker man da hat und dann quasi dann sagen kann, okay, wenn da Teichen sich befinden, dann werden die beschleunigt,
Man zum Beispiel sagt, okay, sagen wir mal, wäre es möglich, dass das Magnetfeld noch,
drei Größenordnungen höher ist. Warum nicht im Prinzip? Es ist noch physikalisch machbar. Dann kann man quasi vorhersagen, was für Energien dann quasi diese diese Photon, die dann auch beschleunigt werden.
Die Teilchen, die beschleunigt werden, was für Energien dann als Photonen freigesetzt werden. Und 20 Jahre später, nachdem der,
die ersten neu Tonsteine entdeckt wurden, wurde quasi schon vorhergesagt, dass man die im Prinzip auch schon
im Röntgenbereich sehen kann. Unsere ersten Röntgenteleskope,
Ähm wurden dann gleichzeitig auch tatsächlich entwickelt und wurden ähm gen Himmel gesenkt, weil ähm das kann man nicht mehr von der Erdoberfläche ausmachen, weil die Erdatmosphäre
nicht durchlässig ist für Röntgenstrahlung. Das heißt, man braucht tatsächlich ein Weltraumteleskop.
Das erste.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, welche,
da da hätte ich meine Chefin fragen sollen, weil die beschäftigt sich nämlich hauptsächlich mit Rückenstrahlung von Hydronstein. Ähm aber im Prinzip jedes ähm jedes Röckenteleskop das sich mittlerweile im All befindet oder auch im All befunden hat ähm,
hat auch Neutonsterne beobachtet. Also es sind nicht,
nicht der Hauptpunkt, das ist meistens selten der Fall, dass man versucht irgendwie nur einen Fachbereich irgendwie so zu analysieren. Das heißt, er hat immer, es hat immer ein Spektrum, aber,
Neuronensteine sind extrem hell im Röckenbereich. Das heißt, es ist wirklich sehr schwierig, die zu übersehen, wenn man dann in die rechte, richtige Richtung.
Grad mal nachgeschaut. Rosa hat nicht der Erste gewesen, aber auf jeden Fall ein tänischer Durchbruch. Erster äh Röntgensattel Lied schon dreiundsechzig unterwegs.
Aber tatsächlich auch eine Tronscheine beobachtet? Ähm.
Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Kann ich aber mal gucken. Schönen Namen.
Ja aber es ist tatsächlich wirklich so, dass,
diese Logik, dass man irgendwie sagt, okay, wir wissen mittlerweile, dass diese Dinge existieren. Wie kann man die denn noch untersuchen, dass das schon sehr früh angefangen hat, nachdem man dann tatsächlich gesagt hat, dass die existieren. Und da muss man dann halt wirklich auch dann.
Argumentieren, dass es das sich lohnt so ein Teleskop zu bauen.
Danach guckt. Und.
Also das ist wirklich so ein bisschen die Energien, die da eine Rolle spielen. Also man kann das tatsächlich mit Größenordnung ableiten. Also man muss dann teilweise sagen,
die Genauigkeiten, die versteht man halt teilweise heute auch immer noch nicht und man hat irgendwie Ideen, wie dann tatsächlich die die Strahlung tatsächlich auch existiert, aber die die Größenordnung kann man schon abstecken. Das heißt, man kann schon sagen, wenn dieses Objekt existiert,
wird das auch im Rückenbereich abstrahlen.
Uhu war offensichtlich der äh erste Bus jetzt zumindest finden äh konnte in den 70ern, wo dann wirklich mal neuronische ausgemacht wurden konnte.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen ein ein Vektor, ne? Die Röntgen äh Strahlung. Die anderen Vektor hatten wir im Prinzip schon. Das waren äh die Radio äh Wellen. Gibt's noch weitere Wahrnehm.
Also man sieht ähm Neuronensterne ähm also,
Sollte ich noch eins einwerfen, die Nordrodensteine, die über die wir uns bis jetzt unterhalten haben, also die Posare und die Magnetare, die sind isoliert, also es sind freistehende, einzelne Neuronensterne.
Aber auch Neutonsteine, die sich in einem Binärsystem oder in einem Doppelsternsystem befinden. Also wir sehen deutlich mehr Neutonsterne mit einem,
Ähm mit einem Hauptdreistern zusammen, ähm als wir doppelt Neutonsterne sehen. Da können wir nur ein paar von. Aber im Prinzip in den Systemen, die sind relativ alt. Die rotieren sehr, sehr, sehr schnell,
Und da sind die Magnetfelder relativ niedrig. Nur so, damit wir das einmal so völlig abgeschlossen haben, dieses diese Magnetfeldse. In diesen,
Ähm System, wo der Neutonstein quasi Masse akretiert,
Da bildet sich meistens eine Aggressionsscheibe außen rum und diese Aggressionsschreiben und die ähm Aggression von Masse auf auf den Atomstand drauf, die sehen wir tatsächlich auch im Röckenbereich. Also diese Objekte, sowohl die super, super Magnetfeldreichen Magnetare,
als auch die alten mit einem sehr niedrigen Magnetfeld. Die sind beide jeweils im Rönkenbereich sichtbar. Aber aufgrund von anderen physikalischen,
Phänomen, weil in den akretierten Systemen man quasi,
Masse auf den neuronischen Dorf beschleunigt oder das Magnetfeld und das quasi ähm dann strahlt,
Bereich. Also man sieht teilweise dann die die inneren Teile der Aggressionsscheibe.
Mit binären System reden wir jetzt von zwei Neuronenstern, die umeinander äh äh rotieren und Doppelsternsystem ist, wenn das andere Objekt ein normaler Stern ist der dann Wasser abgibt oder wie.
Also für mich ist ein Binärsystem einfach was, was zwei Sterne ist.
Also Systeme in der Hinsicht, wo man ein Doppelsternsystem hat, wo man zwar Neuronensterne hat, da sieht man das nicht, sondern man braucht quasi einen normalen Stern, zum Beispiel so wie die Sonne oder ein bisschen weniger oder,
leichter oder schwerer.
Dann sieht der Notrodenstern-Masse von dem von der Sonne ab und dadurch kommt dann sozusagen diese Aggrektionsscheibe äh dazu. Also da wird so die ganze Zeit einfach noch weiter mit Rasierschaum.
Und das, genau, das sieht man wiederum auch,
im Röntgenbereich. Okay, also das sind so die, die Arten von Naturnstern, die man im Rückenbereich sieht und dann gibt's zusätzlich auch noch
einen weiteren normalen Wellenbereich, der ist im Gamma-Strahlenbereich. Also es sind so die hochenergetischen Teile.
Das elektromagnetischen Spektrums, wo Teilchen wirklich extrem zu hohen Energien beschleunigt werden müssen und das ist,
seit es denn Fami Satelliten gibt. Ähm wirklich klar, dass Neuronensterne,
und auch viele Neutonnenscheine, vor allem wenn sie jung sind auch im Gamma-Strahlenbereich. Strahlung aussenden. Also wir sehen,
tatsächlich dann nicht die Mangeltare im,
Strahlenbereich, sondern ein Großteil der jungen Neutonsteine, die wir auch im Radiobereich sehen und quasi diese Pulse sehen. Da sehen wir auch Pulse im Gamerstrahlenbereich.
Und da ist der das äh sozusagen das das Ding, was gerade liefert.
Genau und auch viel. Es ist auch teilweise sogar so, dass wir ähm.
Signal im Radio Wellenlängenbereich ähm nicht sehen und dann.
Gibt's Informationen vom Fami Satelliten, die man dann quasi.
Korrelieren kann mit dem, was man im Radiowellenlängenbereich sieht und dann quasi neue Radiopulsare so entdecken kann, weil man sie im,
Gamer-Strahlenbereich gesehen hat. Ähm wenn man weiß, wonach man mir sagt, wenn man weiß, wonach man suchen muss, in welcher Frequenz, ähm dann ist es teilweise deutlich einfacher.
So und als ich jetzt äh meine letzte Sendung zu den äh Neurodenstein mit gemacht hatte,
war sie dann schon so ein bisschen aufgeregt ähm vor dem Gespräch, aber konnte so richtig nicht drüber äh reden, weil das war ja so grad so diese Phase
angefangen hat, also der Gravitationswellen äh Detektor in USA so die ersten bestätigten,
Gravitationswellen, Detektionen zu melden und kurz vor unserem Gespräch äh lief schon wieder äh alles heiß und äh,
Es gab einen Verdacht, dass es jetzt auch mal was mit Neutronenstern zu tun haben könnte, denn die erste Dedition war ja sozusagen diese klassische Verschmelzung von zwei Schwarzen.
Löchern, was ja auch vorhergesagt war, was man irgendwie wusste, wo viel ja auch
vorher schon äh mathematisch geleistet wurde, um zu sagen, okay, wenn wir dieses Signal detektieren, dann können wir diesem Signal eine ganze Menge ansehen. Wir können dem ansehen, wie die Masse äh Verteilung dieser beiden,
sind die da zusammengeknallt sind und dann können wir irgendwie auch in etwa auch sagen, ob das jetzt irgendwie ein schwarzes Loch ist oder ob's ein Neutronenstein ist. War aber kein Neutronenstern. So und genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt dieses Gesprächs fand es dann halt irgendwie statt, beziehungsweise äh sprach sich langsam rum, das was äh passiert.
Wir konnten halt in der Sendung noch nicht drüber reden. Ähm Warenneutronster.
Möchtest du mehr dazu wissen.
Ja, würde mich doch mal sehr interessieren, was da jetzt eigentlich bei rausgekommen ist.
Ähm also vielleicht muss ich erst nochmal sagen, das mag für den,
die allgemeinen Personen, die das irgendwie so in den Nachrichten liest, vielleicht jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen,
Ja das ist halt da ist halt was passiert, aber also für wirklich die Leute, die daran arbeiten, das ist unglaublich. Also,
Während ich noch Doktorandin war oder in meinem Grundstudium, hieß es immer, ja, irgendwie soll irgendwie die Signale irgendwann mal entdecken, aber wer weiß, wir sagen schon seit 50 Jahren in den nächsten zehn Jahren passiert ist.
Und während man halt tatsächlich dann so in diesem Stadium ist, wo man dann anfängt, irgendwie in diesem Bereich auch zu arbeiten, dass das dann so was passiert, das ist das war unglaublich. Also die Euphorie, die da wirklich durch diesen gesamten Fachbereich ging, war,
extrem. Ähm und das hat auch wirklich glaube ich so viele Leute nochmal irgendwie motiviert, sich damit zu beschäftigen,
Ähm weil Naturnsterne wie gesagt kennen wir schon seit irgendwie 50 Jahren aber so dann tatsächlich sich nochmal damit zu beschäftigen vorherzusagen, wie das denn auch an einem anderen Teil dieses Multimessens ähm Bereichs aussieht.
Da waren jetzt nicht so viele Leute und mittlerweile sind das schon wirklich noch mal mehr Leute, die sie wirklich dann auch damit beschäftigen.
Ursprünglich hat das mal, wie gesagt, diese dieses gesamte Öffnen des Gravitationswellenfensters. Wie man das so schön nennt, ähm hat angefangen mit der Detektion von zwei schwarzen Löchern, die verschmolzen sind.
Und da war ja im Prinzip schon der Finger schon alle an ein bisschen äh heiß zu laufen, so nach dem Motto okay, wenn wir schwarze Löcher sehen können, dann können wir vielleicht halt auch nur Trönenstände sehen.
Also im Prinzip war das.
Ist für die Leute, die jetzt mit schwarzen Löchern arbeiten, äh entschuldigen aber so als Physiker sagen wir teilweise, ja schwarze Löcher sind langweilig.
Im Prinzip werden die beschrieben durch drei Eigenschaften ihre ihren Spin ihre Masse,
und ihre Ladung. Drei Größen beschreiben eigentlich jedes schwarze Loch. Jetzt haben wir uns schon ungefähr, weiß ich nicht, fast eine Stunde wahrscheinlich über Neutonstein und ihre verschiedenen Ausführungen unterhalten.
Uns eigentlich schon zeigt, dass mal Tonsterne in einer gewisser Weise,
deutlich schwieriger sind zu beschreiben, weil's einfach viel, viel mehr physikalische Phänomene gibt, die man beachten muss, um diesen Stern zu beschreiben.
Und die waren aber auch theoretisch messen kann.
Hoffentlich teilweise auch messen kann, ja. Aber das Problem ist, wenn man tatsächlich nach diesen Signalen sucht,
Da muss man eigentlich teilweise wissen, wonach man sucht. Also wie das teilweise gemacht wird, ist, dass man quasi theoretisch vorhersagt, wie das Signal aussehen soll, wonach man dann tatsächlich sucht und dann.
Schaut man sich den gesamten Datensatz an Gravitationswellensignal, den man hat an und versucht das quasi zu korrelieren mit dem, was man erwartet.
Für schwarze Löcher,
ist das die dieses Signal, wir nennen bezeichnen das Asswellenform oder Waveform, also das hat eine bestimmte Charakteristik, je nachdem, wie sich die zwei schwarzen Löcher wie schnell die rotieren ähm da weiß man schon ungefähr so, da wo man nochmal gucken soll.
Im Neutronensteinfall war das nicht so ganz klar. Also man weiß nicht so hundertprozentig,
wie genau den diese diese Verschmelzung vonstatten geht. Also wir haben ungefähr Ideen, aber es ist wirklich nicht so klar, wie das genau funktioniert, weil die Physik, die tatsächlich auch im Inneren des Neuronensterns vonstatten geht,
können wir nicht hundertprozentig beschreiben. Also was uns fehlt, ist diese sogenannte Zustandsgleichung.
Also wir wissen nicht, was wirklich im Inneren des Neutronenstands passiert, weil wir wissen nicht genau, wie sich Materie bei solchen,
verhält. Also wir können so die äußersten Schichten vom Naturstern relativ gut beschreiben, aber die innersten Schichten, die sind dichter wie der Atomkern auf der Erde, das heißt, wir können das tatsächlich nicht herstellen,
Das beschreibt halt im Prinzip, sagen wir mal, 90 Prozent des Sterns, wo wir ungefähr nur Ideen haben.
Wenn man jetzt aber dieses Signal vorhersagen möchte, dann muss man im Prinzip eine Annahme machen, wie denn tatsächlich auch dieses Innere von diesem Stern sich verhält und wie sich das dann auch wirklich verhält,
zwei Sterne anfangen, sich nah umeinander zu bewegen.
Ähm dass das eine ähm dass diese zwei Naturenstände tatsächlich Gravitationswellen erzeugen wird. Das war schon vorher klar, ähm weil,
Ich habe eben gesagt, dass es auch diese neu Tonstände gibt,
Doppelsternsystem, wo man zwei Notrollenstern hat, die um anderen sich umeinander bewegen und man hat tatsächlich dieses Thema auch mit Posaunen entdeckt. Also man weiß auch, dass es diese Systeme gibt und im Prinzip,
für ein spezielles System, das ist der für den ähm für den Entdeckung, die ähm beiden Herren den Nobelpreis bekommen haben. Da konnte man quasi vorhersagen, dass die ähm diesen zwei Neutronensterne,
Die nähern sich aneinander an, weil sie sich umeinander bewegen und quasi Gravitationswellen aussenden. Also kompakte Objekte.
Verändern die Raumzeit um sich rum und das kostet Energie. Das heißt, die zwei ähm Neuronensterne in diesem Hals in Taylor Polster System wurden beobachtet, wie sie Energie verlieren und das hat quasi direkt,
Zusammengepasst mit der Vorhersage des Energieverlustes. Ähm in der einsteinschen Kavitationstheorie. Das heißt, man wusste schon, dass dass da tatsächlich auch messbar sein sollte, aber man hattet also man hat das Hals und Tatersystem.
Noch nicht in
beobachtet in dem Gravitationswellenspektrum, weil es das Signal in dem Bereich viel, viel, viel schwächer ist als für die zwei verschmelzenden Neuronensterne, die wir dann tatsächlich beobachtet haben.
Ähm von den zwei Sternen, die tatsächlich verschmolzen sind, da hatten wir keinen elektromagnetischen,
ähm priccourse, also wir wussten nicht, dass dass diese zwei Neutronnensteine existieren, die sind sehr, sehr, sehr weg von uns. Das heißt, wir haben die tatsächlich auch nicht im elektromagnetischen Bereich,
Vorher gesehen, wir haben die erst aufgrund ihres Verschmelzungs ähm Signals tatsächlich auch dann detektiert.
Also das war jetzt sozusagen das Ergebnis dieser äh Detektion, äh die ich vorhin angesprochen habe. Es waren zwei Neuronensterne, die miteinander verschmelzen. Das das konnte man dann relativ schnell aus diesem Signal ableiten und das war dann insofern besonders eben, wie schon gesagt, äh
Man noch gar nicht, war vollkommen neu. Gab's denn in irgendeiner Form auch die Möglichkeit
denen dann äh nachträglich beizukommen, dass man jetzt sagt, okay, alles klar, wir haben das äh gemeldet. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es
dauert hat bis zur Veröffentlichung aber ist ja so ein bisschen die Idee bei den Gravitationswellendetektionen, aber ich glaube zu dem Zeitpunkt gab's nur
Die beiden Leigos, ne, das heißt.
Gab auch das in Italien das Wirke.
Hat er schon mitgemessen? Ah okay, gut, dann dann war's ja quasi die erste, die man auch so äh
quasi dann über diese drei Punkte der Messung kann man ja relativ klar sagen, okay wir müssen jetzt in die Richtung schauen, um zu gucken, ob da irgendwas passiert ist. Äh fand das statt und ist da was detektiert worden?
Das Faszinierendste an diesem Verschmelzen, dieser zweinetonscheune ist, dass man das tatsächlich nicht nur,
im Gravitationswellenfenster gesehen hat, sondern auch im Elektromagnetischen. Und in der Hinsicht war diese erste Detektion eigentlich was Besonderes, weil davor hat dachten Menschen oder dachten wir eigentlich, dass irgendwie
dieses Verschnelsen der 20 Tonten Channel, das können wir dann vielleicht schon sehen, aber das wirklich das auch koinzitiert mit einer Beobachtung,
Elektromagnetischen, das war nicht so klar. Und was man da tatsächlich gesehen hat, ist wirklich faszinierend. Also diese zwei Neutonnensterne,
Wenn die sich umeinander bewegen, also wir konnten quasi die Masse vorhersagen aufgrund des Gravitationswellensignals, das heißt, das hat uns dann so ein bisschen in die richtige Richtung für dieses für dieses Neutonstein Neuronensteinsystem geleitet.
Wie schnell ging denn diese Information rum? Also ich meine es gab die Detektion, wie lange hat's denn dann gedauert, bis sie sich sicher waren.
Die die triggern, also quasi die die diese Pipeline ist völlig automatisiert, das heißt die nehmen ständig, wenn die Interphemeter im On-Modus sind,
Neben die ständig Datin auf und die die werten automatisch immer diese gesamten Signale, von denen ein Großteil fake ist, also durch irgendwelche Umgebungsstörungen erzeugt werden, nehmen die auf und werten die aus,
Und innerhalb kürzester Zeit wurde dann quasi getriggert, dass das tatsächlich auch ein Signal sein könnte.
Was hast du in kürzester Zeit? Was ist denn da die kürzeste Zeit.
Wir reden hier von von Physik Sekunden bis Minuten bis das dann.
Okay, gut. Mhm, mhm.
Ähm jetzt,
ging das in der Hinsicht aber noch eine noch einen Schritt weiter, weil also diese gesamten Teleskope sowohl im im elektromagnetischen Wellenbereich als auch für den Gravitationswellenbereich.
Wenn da irgendwas passiert, dann ist das eigentlich öffentlich zugänglich oder Leute wissen, dass dann da auch was passiert. Jetzt war aber nicht nur ein Signal im Gravitationswellendetektor, sondern.
Zwei Sekunden nach dem Eingang des Triggers für das Gravitationswellensignal wurde auch ein Gameray Burst, also ein Gammerstrahlenausbruch ähm vom Teleskop beobachtet.
Das war zwei Sekunden nach dem Gravitationswellensignal und es hat nur zwei Sekunden gedauert ähm und das.
Im selben Bereich.
Im sehr im im selben Himmelbereich und zwar also das kann man deutlich besser lokalisieren als den Ursprung des Gravitationswellensignals,
Also man kann das zwar triangulieren mit diversen ähm also mit drei Detektoren in Italien, zwei in den USA.
Man kann dann quasi schon sagen ungefähr wo das sein soll, aber der Bereich ist immer noch relativ groß, also man kann da nicht sagen, okay mit dem optischen Teleskop gucken Sie mal dahin. Das ist einfach.
Man man weiß zumindest schon mal auf welcher Seite der Erde man irgendwo schauen muss sozusagen, ja? Mhm.
Also man das sind so so sicherartige ähm Bereiche, die dann da irgendwie so ähm vorhergesagt werden, wo das dann her kam, aber ist wirklich schwierig, das dann aufgrund des Gravitationswellensignals.
Alleine wirklich zu lokalisieren.
Solange es mir mit nur mit drei zu tun haben, äh das kann sich ja auch nochmal verfeinern in.
Aber das Coole in der Hinsicht war wirklich, dass dieses Gammastrahlendsignal relativ genau lokalisiert werden konnte und dann viele anderen Wellenlängenbereiche im Optischen, im Infraroten, im Röntgen, dann sich darauf ausgerichtet haben.
Also das war dann sozusagen das Alarmsignal, also Gravitationswellen, zwei Sekunden später äh macht Fami äh äh so was, dann dauert's wahrscheinlich ein paar Minuten, bis das sozusagen gesicherte Information ist.
Aber das so so gut sind die dann schon miteinander vernetzt, dass dann diese Korrelation mit der Gamma-Strahlendetection und der Gravitationsdetection,
wird das dann auch schon automatisch zusammengeführt oder muss dann irgendwie noch einer daneben sitzen und sagen, Moment mal da und da.
Es kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, also viele von diesen Teleskopen
also die Betreiber reden schon tatsächlich miteinander. Ähm teilweise manche Teleskope, also bestimmtes optisches Teleskop, das hat auch unter Umständen einen viel größeren Radius als zum Beispiel ähm ein Röntgenteleskop. Deshalb man sieht da unter Umständen auch viel, viel mehr. Das heißt,
die haben das dann teilweise auch schon in ihrer also die waren halt am Beobachten von irgendwas anderem, haben dann halt ein Signal gesehen.
Automatisch, weil die halt einfach den den Himmelsbereich abgedeckt haben. Aber andere Teleskope wurden dann quasi ähm also das wird tatsächlich schon geteilt, wenn da irgendwas triggert,
auf der Family Seite, ähm das heißt, die haben sich dann halt quasi darauf ausgerichtet. Über manche Teleskopen dauert es Tage, bis das dann wirklich machbar ist. Bei anderen geht das viel, viel schneller. Das kommt aber.
Nicht so, dass die sich was anderes zu tun hätten gerade und äh wichtige Beobachtungen machen, weil da stirbt ja bestimmt irgendein Wissenschaftler dann auch einen Tod, wenn dann so ein Alarmsignal reinkommt, so ah meine Beobachtung.
Es gibt es gibt solche ähm also ich sollte dazu sagen, ich benutze selber keine Teleskop, ich bin aber sehr glücklich, wenn mir jemand die Daten zur Verfügung stellt,
Ähm aber es gibt sogenannte Target of Overtunity. Ähm Beobachtung, wo man halt dann quasi innerhalb kürzester Zeit quasi sagen kann, okay, ich möchte so eine Beobachtung
ähm weil das halt irgendwie ein katalistisches Phänomen ist, das man nicht vorhersagen kann und dann haben Leute quasi Zeit zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen für solche Beobachtungen und dann wird halt gesagt, okay, das sieht extrem wichtig aus. Lass uns mal da was hingucken.
Also was weiß ich, wenn jetzt eine Supernova auf einmal losgehen würde in unserer Nachbarschaft und so weiter, da da wird wahrscheinlich alles äh komplett abge.
In der Hinsicht ähm wurde da sicher die die Beobachtung von manchen Leuten unterbrochen, aber auch für was extrem Wichtiges in.
Ja, okay, gut, aber äh nur mal um zu verstehen, was was da äh passiert ist. Also diese beiden Events kamen dann irgendwie zusammen und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass halt ähm viele, nicht alle, aber viele Teleskope aus den unterschiedlichsten Wellenbereichen
die in irgendeiner Form überhaupt die Möglichkeit hatten, da drauf zu schauen. Äh manche sind ja einfach auf der falschen Seite der Erde dann in dem Moment gewesen, äh haben sich das irgendwie angeschaut,
Man hat dann sozusagen jetzt wirklich mal so einen totalen Multi-Messenger-Event,
also getriggert von den Gravitationswellen und den Gamma-Strahlen kam dann irgendwie alles mit dazu und was,
wusste man dann daraus, was es äh denn nun wirklich passiert ist.
Ich sollte vielleicht noch sagen, also im Prinzip hatten wir Multimessenger auch schon vorher, weil wir sehen ja Neutrinos, also die Leute, die sich mit Neutrinus beschäftigen, sind immer ein bisschen vorsichtig, weil also im Prinzip gab's ist Neutrino ein anderer.
Aber so ein kombiniertes Event ist ja, ist ja relativ äh selten.
Das stimmt. Also es passiert wirklich sehr selten, aber also das Coole ist, im Falle von 200 Tonnensternen. Wenn die verschmelzen, ist das dann halt eben Materie,
nicht hinter einem Ereignishorizont versteckt ist, so wie das bei einem Schwarzen Loch passiert. Das heißt, wenn zwei schwarze Löcher verschmelzen, sehen wir halt,
keine Materie, die dadurch beeinflusst wird,
Wir aber jetzt zwei Neusteine haben, was passiert während diese Objekte sich wirklich nah aneinander bewegen, ist das der leichtere von den zwei Neuronenstern durch die Gezeitenkraft des anderen quasi erst verformt und dann wirklich,
aufgemalt wird. Also die Materie an sich bleibt nicht in einem Stern vorhanden, sondern das wird wirklich aufgemahlen und bildet dann auch so eine Aggressionsscheibe, wie wir das vorhin hatten,
die sich um den ähm schwereren Naturnstern bewegt und dadurch wird halt extrem, also die die Energie, die da frei wird aufgrund dieser Bindungsenergie, des Sterns und der Rotationsenergie, die wird halt quasi dadurch freigesetzt. Also wir haben in diesem System,
quasi so eine Akgrektionsscheibe, die aber gleichzeitig energiefreisetzt in anderen Formen.
Und das Gavigationswellensignal an dem Zeitpunkt kann man dann da tatsächlich auch beobachten bis diese zwei also der aufgemahlene Stern und der tatsächlichen Naturnstern verschmelzen.
Sieht man dann auch wirklich schon zu dem Zeitpunkt her.
Sobald das dann der Stern aufgemalmt ist, obwohl die tatsächliche Zeitreihenfolge auch nicht so hundertprozentig klar ist, aber das sorgt dafür, dass da tatsächlich die Jets produziert werden. Und die Jets sind das, was dann tatsächlich uns die Gammastrahlung produziert hat.
Also schätze diese speziellen, starken Bursts von von.
Burst Sea so bisschen gerichtet sind ähm wieder wie so ein Lichtkegel ähm.
Bei den schwarzen Löchern zum Beispiel manchmal sieht.
Ja, genau.
Dann dafür verantwortlich gemacht wurden, dass man tatsächlich auch dieses ähm Gammastrahlensignal nach dem Gravitationswellensignal sieht und zusätzlich zu diesen Jets wird er auch deutlich mehr Materie freigesetzt und zwar zu solchen
Kondition, dass die Teilchen wieder so ein bisschen aufgelöst werden, also die die Teichen, die dann im Prinzip da entstehen, die.
Werden weggeblasen und in dem Prozess werden die quasi wieder verändert in einer gewissen Weise und zwar so, dass,
Da jetzt Teilchen entstehen können, also ist ein bisschen so wie ein Teilchen beschleunige auf der Erde, wo wo man unter Umständen ähm ein Atomkern hat und dann da irgendwie andere,
Nuklearteilchen einfügt. Ähm und dadurch halt zum Beispiel sehr, sehr, sehr viel schwerere Teiche machen kann. Und genau das ist dann tatsächlich auch da passiert, also während dieses sogenannten,
Ausbruchs, also im Englischen nennen wir das den Merchy Burst, also es wäre so sozusagen ein Verschmelzungsausbruch.
Was da passiert ist, wird im Prinzip auch als Kilo Nova bezeichnet, also es ist ein sehr energiereiche Ausstoßungsprozess, das ist nicht eine Explosion in dem Sinne, aber es ist halt was, was wirklich hell aussieht durch die freigesetzte Energie.
Also die Kielanova ist das, was man tatsächlich auch dann in den anderen Wellenlängenbereichen gesehen hat und aufgrund dieser dieser hohen Energien, die da vorhanden sind,
man da tatsächlich auch nachweisen können, dass da viele von den schweren Elementen, die wir so auf der Erde haben hergestellt wurden. Also durch dieses,
Teilchen beschleuniger Experiment, wo wir irgendwelche Kerne haben, wo wir was anderes einfügen, sind ein Großteil wahrscheinlich das Gold, das wir so um uns herum haben, entstanden. Das heißt,
Hat wirklich direkte Einblicke geliefert in in die nukleare Synthese von von schweren, von schweren Elementen.
Unser Sonnensystem entstehen konnte, muss erstmal ein paar Neuronensterne auseinander fliegen oder beziehungsweise ineinander äh fliegen, weil nur da kommen diese wirklich schweren äh.
Also es ist nicht nur klar, nur da, also ähm Supernova-Explosion an sich führen auch dazu, dass diese,
Teilchen im Prinzip beschleunigt werden können und Nuklearteilchen irgendwie dann da eingefügt werden können in die Kerne. Das heißt im Prinzip funktioniert da auch ein Teil der Nukleysynthese aber es ist nicht so klar zu welchen Größenordnungen und wie genau das funktioniert,
oder wie groß der Anteil ist ähm an der Herstellung der einzelnen ähm Elemente in welchem Prozess. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall klar von der Vorhersage, wie diese Kilo Nova aussah ähm und was wir auch tatsächlich beobachtet haben, dass dann,
sehr, sehr, sehr großer Teil an den schweren Elementen wie Uran, Platin, Gold, tatsächlich auch in diesem Prozess hergestellt werden wird.
Könnte auch sein, dass Gold auch in der Supernova entsteht.
Glaube, das ist immer noch der Fall, dass das auch sein könnte zu bestimmten Teilen.
Aber auf jeden Fall so in der Kilo Nova geht nicht ohne Gold aus.
Also wenn so eine Kilonummer stattfindet, das heißt jedes Mal, wenn so weit solche Neutronensterne,
ähm verschmelzen und diese Seitenkräfte quasi wie so ein Stern aufbrechen, dann wird Gold produziert. Ich sollte dazu sagen, dass das im Prinzip auch funktionieren kann oder dass diese ein bestimmtes ähm.
Elektromagnetisches Signal, so eine Kilo Nova auch produziert werden kann, wenn dann eine Tronstern mit einem Schwarzen Loch fusioniert. Und 2 solche Wände wurden tatsächlich auch letztes Jahr entdeckt,
wo auch quasi der Neutronnenstern durch die Gezeiten Kraft von dem schwarzen Loch,
verformt und dann aufgemahlen wird und da eben auch so ein elektromantisches Signal im Prinzip erzeugt werden könnte. Wir haben das für diese zwei ähm Phänomene aber tatsächlich nicht.
Das Ergebnis ist ja wieder ein schwarzes Loch.
Also in dem Fall ähm ist das Ergebnis auf jeden Fall ein schwarzes Loch. In dem Fall, wo wir zwei Notronensteine haben, die miteinander fusionieren,
kann es im Prinzip unterschiedliche Arten an Endprodukt geben. Also je nachdem, wie schwer die zwei Neutonnensteine vorher sind, sagen wir meistens, wer zwei sehr leichte Neuronensterne und irgendwie,
eins Komma zwei und eins Komma drei Sonnenmassen. Wenn die miteinander verschmelzen, dann kann es sein, dass die Gesamtmasse tatsächlich noch unter der maximalen Masse für die Stabilität eines Neuronensterns fallen würde,
Unter Umständen können wir auch, wenn zwei Nuthronsteine miteinander fusionieren, einen stabilen, weiteren neuen Thronstein erstellen.
Relativ oft, dass da ein schwarzes Loch bei raus.
Also die Statist also wie genau die Größenordnung sind, wie oft das passiert, das hängt wie gesagt auch unter Umständen von der
Ähm von der Zustandsgleichung ab, die wir nicht kennen, weil das einem quasi erzählt, wie stabil denn der Stern ist für eine bestimmte Masse. Deshalb kennen wir diese bestimmte Obergrenze für die Stabilität des Naturnsterns nicht so richtig, aber.
Wenn man irgendwie zwei Sonnenmassen, Neutronenstern mit einem zwei Sonnenmassen, Neutonnenstern verschmilzt, dann kommt auf jeden Fall ein schwarzes Loch dabei raus.
Das heißt, die wahrscheinlichste These für den Ursprung des Materials, was man für ein ordentliches Goldkettchen braucht, ist zwei Neuronensterne knallen zusammen und im Rahmen dieser
dieses zusammenprall Verschmelzungs Explosions wird so viel schweres Material
erzeugt aber dann eben auch rausgeschmissen, bevor es,
vom Schwarzen Loch äh äh ausgefangen werden kann, wird dann irgendwann in irgend so einer Gasnebel äh Wolke äh eingefangen von irgendwie äh anderen Teilchen und dann bildet sich eine Sonne und dann.
Ein ganz schön langer Weg.
Aber so wird es wohl gewesen sein.
Wow. Also das war auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich mächtiges äh Ereignis und ähm ja das ist ja dann in gewisser Hinsicht
dieses Event ist ja dann bahnbrechend eigentlich in vielerlei Hinsicht, weil man hat ja dann auch das erste Mal quasi wirklich das beobachtet. Also es ist ja dann sozusagen jetzt auch mal wieder raus aus der Theorie äh rein ähm ja Experimental ist jetzt vielleicht grad nicht, aber zumindest so äh nachweisbar.
Also da da funktioniert jetzt auch wirklich also Hut ab zu den Leuten, die einerseits.
Bauen, weil das ist wirklich extrem kompliziert, dass man solche winzigen Signale tatsächlich auch wirklich beobachten kann,
und dann auch die Leute, die die Software schreiben, die sich dann auch tatsächlich damit beschäftigen, wie ich denn aus irgend so einem Salat an Gravitationswellensignal dann auch wirklich so was herausfiltern kann. Das ist wirklich nicht einfach.
Ähm jetzt weiß ich nicht, wir hatten ähm drüber gesprochen, wie man.
Quasi messen äh kann. Wir hatten halt die Röntgen äh Strahlung. Wir hatten generell natürlich die äh Radiowellen. In dem Bereich wird aber,
quasi immer noch am meisten zu holen. Und ich meine, wenn man jetzt sagt
3000 Neuronensterne äh ist ja so mehr so im zehn hoch drei Bereich und zehn hoch acht oder neun können's geben. Da ist ja eigentlich noch eine ganze Menge zu holen. So wie äh geht man denn da jetzt
bei, weil ich habe würde jetzt mal vermuten, dass Interesse da dran, diese Zahl von 3tausend doch mal signifikant auszuweiten, dürfte doch vergleichsweise hoch sein.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall so. Also vielleicht sage ich erst was zu dem, was wir denn da planen und dann noch eine weitere Sache zu dem, was woran ich eigentlich arbeite, weil das ist irgendwie im Prinzip auch daran angelehnt. Also.
Wir sehen ungefähr 3000 Neutonnensterne.
Und ein Großteil davon sehen wir ähm in unserer eigenen Miesstraße. Also wir sehen teilweise eine Handvoll, auch in den maggelanischen Wolken, aber ein Großteil dieser Naturstände sind tatsächlich.
Unserer Galaxie bezogen. Wir sehen da, wie ich vorher aber schon gesagt habe, auch wirklich nur einen kleinen Teil.
Und im Prinzip spielen da diverse Punkte rein, die das da so quasi verhindern, dass wir einfach noch mehr sehen und die Weiterentwicklung,
die dann tatsächlich passiert, ist sagen wir mal kommt von irgendwie zwei Seiten. Also auf einer Seite braucht man ein besseres Teleskop, also man braucht ein sensitiveres Teleskop oder unter Umständen.
Mehrere Teleskope zusammen, die dann quasi in einer bestimmten Aufreihungsfunktion, also wir nennen das dann eine Ray
ähm Setup, die dann tatsächlich auch sich ähm mit der Suche wirklich beschäftigen und auf der Seite wird gerade also das ist, was es auch schon seit Jahrzehnten in Planung,
eine neue Zusammenstellung an Radioteleskopen gebaut, die unter dem ähm Titel des laufen. Also das ist,
Nebenteils war das Forschungskonklame, das im Prinzip quasi das beste Radiotelesko baut, ähm dass wir auf der Erde haben werden.
Beschäftigt sich nicht nur mit Neuronenstern und Posaunen, sondern es hat einen extrem vielfältigen ähm Anwendungsbereich auch im Bereich der,
Galaxieforschung und so weiter, also Neutronensterne sind ein Teil des Ganzen, aber das wird quasi im Moment gebaut, teilweise in Australien, wo es eine eine extrem große Geschichte an.
Radioteleskop, Untersuchungen schon gibt und dort auch existiert, also gibt's wirklich viel viel Wissen in dem Bereich, das heißt, da wird gerade ein Teil dieses
gesamten Radio Schleskops gebaut, also es sind viele einzelne Radioteleskope, die dann zusammengeschalten werden. Und ein anderer Teil, der wird in Südafrika gebaut, wo's auch eine große Geschichte an diesen,
diese Art von von Untersuchung von dem Universum gibt und an beiden Orten sollte ich dazu sagen, die wurden auch unter anderem daher ausgewählt, dass es dort gebaut wird, weil's da auch relativ wenig,
Störungen gibt und also einfach noch Regionen gibt, wo wenig Leute wohnen. Weil das ist wirklich was, was man braucht, um tatsächlich auch vorhersagen zu können,
man dann auch was sehen kann, dass man garantieren kann, dass da nicht irgendwie die Mikrowelle vom Nachbarn irgendwie dann,
ein zusätzliches Signal erzeugt. Also wenn man ein super sensitives Radio Teleskop hat, dann sieht man dann halt auch wirklich alles und man sieht halt auch alles, was auf der Erde an sich stattfindet oder jedes einzelne, jeden einzelnen Satelliten, jedes einzelne Flugzeug,
Das heißt, das das muss man schon auch so ein bisschen planen, dass das dann auch tatsächlich passt.
Aber das ist jetzt tatsächlich auch in der näheren Planungsphase, also es gibt schon so pre-curse Varianten vom SKA, die auch tatsächlich schon laufen.
Passfinder.
Genau ähm und dann auch teilweise Radio Teeskope, die dann quasi danach angegliedert werden, wo dann quasi die Software weiterentwickelt wird, weil das ist so der andere Teil.
Dann sensitives Teleskop hat heißt es noch lange nicht, dass man das tatsächlich dann auch beobachtet.
Die Menge an Daten, die da aufgenommen wird, ist unglaublich. Das heißt aber, wenn man irgendwie bestimmte Datenmengen hat oder bestimmte Datenvolumen hat,
Da kann man das als Mensch nicht mehr alleine durchschauen und das ist teilweise also wir haben ja vorhin über Detektionsvariante geredet, die dann da so ein,
Schreiberpapier ausgelesen hat, das funktioniert einfach nicht mehr, wenn man so viel Daten hat. Das heißt, ähm da wird auch viel, viel im Moment,
dran gearbeitet, wie man das dann automatisieren kann, dass man diese Dinge dann tatsächlich auch findet. Und da ist spielt maschinelles Lernen, also Maschinenlearning schon wirklich eine große Rolle,
Es hat einfach wirklich man braucht eine Möglichkeit, sich mit extrem viel Datenvolumen beschäftigen zu können.
Das ist nicht so einfach. Das heißt, so dieses diese Idee, dass man quasi die Detektionsmethode verbessert und zusätzlich auch ein besseres Telespot baut.
Größenordnung, die wir immer wenn so haben, ist, dass wir quasi von diesen dreitausend
Teleskop ist Curry Meteate sichtlich auch gebaut wird, dann mal ungefähr auf 30.000 die Anzahl anheben. Also die Idee ist, dass es ungefähr ein Faktor zehn mehr Neuenstände geben wird,
Das heißt, diese einzelnen Klassen, die wir vorher besprochen haben, werden unter Umständen auch Faktor zehn größer, das heißt, man man kann da deutlich besser Statistik betreiben und dann besser vorhersagen, wo man denn tatsächlich auch was sieht und welche Theorien denn,
passen auf diese gesamte Population, weil es ja immer noch alles Neuronensterne.
Und es sieht so aus, dass das tatsächlich dann auch wirklich alle der Natursterne, die wir bei uns in der Galaxy beobachten können, tatsächlich auch abdecken sollen. Also das sind wieder die, die wo wirklich,
Dieser Radiostrahl auch tatsächlich über uns hinweg fickt, ähm die wir dann auch tatsächlich sehen können.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, soll das so bis Ende dieses Jahrzehnts äh gebaut sein, 2029 ist halt immer so mit den Vorhersagen äh äh in dem Bereich immer so eine Sache ähm,
tief gelegen in ähm,
äh Australien jetzt mit dieser Passfindermission. Es gibt ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie verteilt sich das jetzt mit Südafrika und in äh also man baut quasi an beiden Standorten mehr oder weniger dasselbe, damit man.
Ganz ehrlich, weiß ich nicht, ob das immer noch die momentane Design-Anlage ist, aber es gibt so diverse Design-Strategien wie quasi, wo was gebaut wird und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht, was im Moment der der momentane Stand ist.
Von von der Zivilisation äh gibt ja zum Beispiel dieses große äh Teleskop ähm bei.
Was auch irgendwann mal richtig schön äh im Nichts stand, aber dann hat sich halt Purse in den letzten Jahrzehnten soweit ausgedehnt, dass das äh äh jetzt schon ein richtiges Problem ist. Hier will man also so richtig schön ins Hinterland, wo eigentlich auch niemand auch nur drüber nachden,
so ein bisschen wie mit der Atacama-Wüste, das ist ja auch noch mal so ein Vorteil dieses Standorts neben vielen anderen, dass da halt einfach nix anderes ist, was groß reinstrahlt, aber das sind natürlich dann auch,
Orte, äh wo es auch schwierig ist, die Logistik äh aufrechtzuerhalten, weil das dann halt irgendwie,
heiß und trocken und weit weg und äh alles mögliche Lebenserhalten, diese Systeme,
äh äh als der ganze ähm Klimbim, der dann auch mit äh dranhängt. Aber ich würde gerne nochmal auf diese Machine Sache reingehen, weil das bedeutet ja im Prinzip, dass man jetzt bis zu diesem,
Zeitpunkt, wenn man einmal davon ausgeht, dass das jetzt eben in was weiß ich, acht Jahren steht, dann fallen diese Daten an.
Heißt ja, man muss ja erstmal,
Man muss ja erstmal wissen, worauf man schaut. Also womit wird denn dann das sozusagen gefüttert, um dann letzten Endes aus diesen neuen Daten äh Hinz auf tatsächlich existierende Neuronensteinen gewinnen zu können?
Das ist äh wird auch von zwei Seiten angegangen. Auf einer Seite haben wir tatsächlich schon Beobachtungsdaten, also für für die,
Neutronzenne, die die Welt tatsächlich beobachtet haben, haben wir Unmengen an diesen Einzelpulsen und im Prinzip,
ist die die Detektionsvariante immer noch, dass man irgendwie versucht, diese einzelnen Pulse auf einem irgendwie auf so,
ausm Rauschen auszulesen im Prinzip. Ähm das heißt, man hat Unmengen von diesen tatsächlichen Aufnahmen schon vorhanden. Das heißt, das ist eine Möglichkeit, wo man sagen kann, okay,
Wir versuchen unseren Algorithmus so zu trainieren, dass er quasi diese Dinger auch tatsächlich herauslesen kann,
Das heißt, der erste Ansatz wäre, man sollte versuchen,
tatsächlich die, die man schon gefunden hat, auch wieder zu wieder so rezitieren, also dass das tatsächlich auch machbar wäre. Das wäre quasi so der der erste Ansatz, dass man sagt, okay,
Mein Algorithmus sollte zumindest so gut sein, dass er das, was wir schon kennen, auch wieder findet in irgendeinem Daten.
Und dann ähm also das ist ein großer Teil und da gibt's wirklich im Radiobereich für diese,
auch wirklich Unmengen an an Trainingsdaten, weil es einfach viele von diesen einzelnen Pulsen gibt,
wenn Neutronenstern alle 1,3 Sekunden so einen Puls aussendet und nicht mein Radioliste da drauf richtet, dann kann ich schon viele Daten ansammeln und da gibt's wirklich große Datenbanken.
Die da auch aufgestellt werden und auch schon teilweise seit seit Jahrzehnten, eben seit die ersten Matronensterne, gefunden wurden. Die zweite Seite ist, dass man,
Das Ganze trainiert aufgrund von Simulationen. Simulationen beraut im Prinzip darauf, dass wir irgendwie eine bestimmte Art,
ähm haben unsere Physik, also die die unter die die grundlegenden Theorien quasi so aufzustellen, dass wir das dann.
So wieder logisch,
aneinander reihen, dass wir in Prinzip am Ende die Beobachtung haben, die wir tatsächlich dann auch von einem Radiotelesk bekommen würden. Und das ist so ein so ein Ansatz, mit dem ich mich auch beschäftige, den man als Populationssynthese beschreibt, also man versucht im Prinzip,
diese gesamten neuronstellen, die es überall in der Galaxy gibt, von grundlegenden physikalischen Konzepten her vorherzusagen, dann entwickelt man die quasi also,
Man modelliert wirklich, wie die sich über Millionen, zehntausende, hunderttausende von Jahren entwickeln und wie.
Man nach bestem Wissen im Moment vorhersagen kann, wie quasi ähm Strahlung ähm aussenden und wie das dann wiederum,
die Galaxien sich propagiert, je nachdem wo der Notrodenstern sich befindet theoretisch im theoretischen Modell und dann sagen kann, okay, wenn der so hell ist und das Teleskop so gut, dann sollte ich im Prinzip so und so viele Neuronenstände dann tatsächlich auch sehen.
Das ist so der der andere Ansatz.
Ähm wo man dann sagen kann, okay wir würden dann vorhersagen, dass sich die Naturenten, die wir dann tatsächlich beobachten, so und so verhalten und dann,
rückschlüssig mehr über den tatsächlichen,
Input, also die die tatsächlichen Annahmen, die ursprünglich gemacht haben, dass wir dann da so viel so viele Sterne quasi beobachten, dass wir sagen können, okay unser Eingangsmodell war so falsch und es haben ein Modell, dass wir quasi.
Nicht wirklich an die realen Beobachtungsdaten rankommen. Das ist dann die andere Seite.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, das wird schon alles irgendwie funktionieren, wird das wahrscheinlich auch mal so ein bisschen dauern, ich denke mal so, diese Machine Learning Option, das ist ja schon jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, eine, das ist ja jetzt schon keine, keine Zauberwissenschaft mehr, das
äh schon äh gut abgehangen, da weiß man irgendwie äh äh schon in etwa und gerade mit so einem guten Basisdatensatz und so einen guten Trainings
Modell sollte eigentlich was Brauchbares bei rauskommen. Also es ist sozusagen absehbar, dass wir eben einen sehr viel größeren neuronensternzoo aufgebaut bekommen.
Immer noch nix im Vergleich zu dem, was es wahrscheinlich äh gibt, aber das heißt ja, dass man irgendwie noch mehr äh hat, um damit zu arbeiten. Und da ist ja dann und das würde ich jetzt gerne noch mal zum Schluss äh aufgreifen, die Idee, weil das eigentlich sehr schönes
passt zu dem, was wir bisher gemacht haben, weil jetzt sind die Gravitationswellendetektionen benutzt worden, um die Neutronensterne äh zu finden. Und jetzt könnte man im Prinzip die Neuronensterne wiederum dazu benutzen, um wieder die Gravitationswellen zu finden. Mit diesen äh mit dieser Idee des Pulser-Timing
sehr full Circle.
In gewisser Weise. Also das ist quasi, also man muss sich das wirklich so ein bisschen vorstellen wie so eine Uhr, die irgendwo im im Weltall sitzt und tatsächlich die.
Das Ticken der Uhr, das das wird quasi dadurch verändert, dass sich Gravitationswellen in dieser Raumzeit bewegen. Ähm und.
Wir haben ja so ein Modell schon, heißt GPS, ja, ist ja.
Im Prinzip also das Prinzip, das Prinzip funktioniert wirklich sehr sehr ähnlich, aber,
das, was tatsächlich dann die Ankunftszeit des Tickens verändert, ist viel, viel grundlegender wie im im Verhältnis zum GPS, wo man tatsächlich dann nur wissen muss, wie lange sich das so ungewohnte Umstände bewegt, sondern weil wirklich halt in
die Raumzeitkrümmung sich verändert, während diese Gravitationswelle sie oder die viele Gravitationswellen sich durch dieses Polstertiming Ray quasi bewegen.
Aber im Prinzip man hat sozusagen so um sich herum und ähm ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit sind diese Posare? Was ist denn so das der weiteste Pulsar, den man äh gefunden hat?
Gute Frage. Also ich würde sagen, auf jeden Fall deutlich mehrere Kilo.
Heißt das äh dass sie alle in der Milchstraße äh sind.
Ein Großteil ja, aber also jetzt müsste ich wissen, wie wie weit die Magelanischen Wolken weg sind, weil das ist glaube ich der weiteste.
Also da gibt's sozusagen äh auch noch einen.
Noch mehrere.
Mehrere, die dort gefunden sind. Äh gucken wir doch mal hier. Große magelanische Wolke 163.000 Lichtjahre was ist das in Pasik.
Wenn ich das jetzt so schnell umrech.
Okay, äh,
Einfach mal 136.000 Likes in Pasik. Dafür gibt's auch Wolfram Alpha wie das müsste einem doch so was eigentlich sagen können. Na komm, Spuck aus.
Ähm noch wird nachgedacht, wo ist die Computation intelligents, wie man sie braucht. Neunundvierzig äh also fünfzig Pasik.
Okay. Das erschreckt mir jetzt ein bisschen wenig.
Das, was Wolfram Alpha sagt, wenn ich sage ach so, nee, Moment, ich glaube, er hat die hundert ah, der hat den Punkt, äh ich habe einen tausender Punkt, okay äh gute Qualitäts äh Kontrolle in der Tat. Es handelt sich um 50 Tausend Par sechs.
Das das 50 Kilo Basic klingt besser, ja.
Ja
Ja, sowas schließen wir daraus. Also der es gibt Neutronensterne in der Magelanschen äh Wolke.
Also die, die man für das benutzt, das sind diese wie ich's vorher gesagt habe, diese Millisekund, die sie extrem ähm oder relativ alt sind, extrem schnell rotieren. Ähm ich ich glaube, da wird man eher die benutzen, die bei uns in der eigenen Milchstraße sich befinden.
Aber je mehr man natürlich davon findet, desto mehr sagen wir mal, wir haben.
Wir finden nochmal irgendwie Faktor zehn mehr Neutonnensterne mit dem SGA, dann hätte man natürlich auch noch mal mit deutlich mehr Kandidaten für dieses Passertiming Ray. Und im Prinzip hast du vorhin auch schon GPS.
Bedeutet, es gibt Leute, die sagen, man könnte also,
das hier auch schon mal probiert. Sollte man sich irgendwie im Universum bewegen wollen, bräuchte man quasi das äquivulente zum GPS auf der Erzgala, damit man quasi weiß, wo man genau ist.
Mhm. So als Nachfolger der Star Trecker.
Sozusagen und im Prinzip eignen sich Posara tatsächlich sehr gut dazu. Also vielleicht weißt du auch ähm auf der Voyager Sonde,
die wir irgendwann mal gegen Ende der Mähstraße geschickt haben, ist auch die Position der Erde im Verhältnis zu,
den den Nächsten ähm Posaunen angegeben, damit im Prinzip sollte die jemand finden, auch die Erde lokalisieren kann.
Pfiffig. Ja, also es ist äh äh ein ein ein schönes Bild vor allem, weil es eben dann auch quasi den ureigensten.
Die ureigenste Struktur des Universums, die Raumzeit,
einfach äh nimmt und irgendwie die ganze äh Krümmung quasi ähm ja berücksichtigt, weil das ja dann letzten Endes die Laufzeiten verändert.
In dem Moment, wo eine Gravitationswelle da durchrauscht, ändert sich das eben.
Also,
für für dieses international Ray werden's wird das also eine einzelne Gravitationswelle, so wie wir das vorher besprochen haben wird da wahrscheinlich nicht messbar sein, sondern das ist quasi,
der Hintergrund,
aller Gravitationswellen, die es quasi im Universum gibt. Also wir nennen bezeichnen das als storchasischen Hintergrund, der quasi dadurch detektierbar ist. Aber es ist halt quasi nicht mehr eine,
eine unbeeinflusste Raumzeit, sondern im Prinzip jeder jeder Stern, jedes Binärsystem ähm produziert eben diese Gravitationswellen.
Die werden ja sich immer weiter im Universum bewegen. Und das erzeugt quasi so ein Hintergrundrauschen, dass man dadurch aber tatsächlich entdecken kann,
Da gibt's Andeutung für, dass das mittlerweile vielleicht tatsächlich möglich ist, aber es wird wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Jahre dauern, bis man das tatsächlich hundertprozentig nachweisen kann.
Und wenn man das nachweisen könnte, was könnte man aus dieser Information herausholen.
Es könnte also man muss quasi dann wieder man man kann sagen, wie stark das Signal ist und ähm wie's aussieht und dann muss man quasi vorher sagen.
Vergleichen passt das mit unser Vorhersagen, wie denn dieses Hintergrundrauschen tatsächlich auch aussieht.
Je nachdem, welche Annahmen man über das Universum so an sich macht, gibt es unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, wie dieses Rauschen aussehen kann. Also teilweise gibt es dann Leute, die sagen, okay, wenn man irgendwie sich einen.
String Theory,
Model überlegt, dann hat das einen bestimmten Einfluss auf wie das Rauschen aussieht oder wenn es zum Beispiel irgendwie bestimmte Therien für die ursprünglichen Phasen ähm die Entstehung des Universums gibt zu Zeiten der Inflation, könnte das das Rauschen beeinflussen und so weiter.
Aber im Prinzip kann man damit das tatsächlich.
Andere Arten von Signalen wieder näher einschränken, wie man das zum Beispiel mit der normalen Gravitationswellen, die wir, was ich sage, normal, das sind alles normale Kamilationen. Die, die wir mit jetzt sagen.
Sozusagen handelsübliche.
Genau nachdem wir die jetzt vor fünf Jahren oder zehn Jahren das erste Mal entdeckt haben sind die schon wieder normal.
Ja, aber ist schön äh schönes Bild, dass im Prinzip die
die die Neurodensterne äh vielleicht unter Umständen mal so der Ursprung einer Messung sein könnten, mit dem man äh
generellen Aussagen über die großen Theorien der Gesamtentstehung des Universums, Big Bang und alles, was da dranhängt, gegebenenfalls
bestätigen vielleicht äh zumindest verfestigen oder auch äh mal ausschließen kann. Das würde ja auch schon äh uns weiterhelfen bei der Vielzahl der verschiedenen Sachen.
Ja, Vanessa jetzt haben wir aber hier äh den großen äh Reigen abgefeiert. Gibt's noch irgendwas, was so.
Noch mit auf den Weg geben möchtest.
Also ich man hat vielleicht gemerkt, ich könnte darüber sehr, sehr, sehr lange reden und auch noch deutlich mehr. Ähm aber ich glaube, wir belassen's mal dabei. Das klingt doch ein ganz rundes Thema.
Auf jeden Fall nicht den Eindruck, dass äh die Themen ausgehen.
Nee, das ist aber auch gut so, wenn wir ja, danke gleichfall.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, ja.